Hey, Shawnee. I was just thinking about, I'm just going, I'm getting really reminiscent of the old days.
Yeah, tell me about it.
Well, I was just thinking about back in the day, you used to be able to get $10 out of manufacture
Hanover ATM. So I was so broke and I'd take $10 out.
And then I could buy a pack of smokes. And I'd go to hot and crusty.
And I could get a coffee and a Danish. And for $0.25, I could buy the New York Post.
And then I'd go to the 87th Street entrance to the 86th Street station on the Upper West Side.
And I'd wait for the subway doors.
嘿，肖尼。我刚才在想，我只是，我开始非常怀念过去的日子了。是啊，跟我说说。嗯，我刚才在想过去的日子，你以前能从汉诺威制造公司的自动取款机里取10美元。我当时穷得叮当响，就取10美元。然后我可以买一包烟。我会去Hot and Crusty店。我可以买杯咖啡和一个丹麦酥。花25美分，我还能买份《纽约邮报》。然后我会走到上西区第86街车站的第87街入口。我会等着地铁门。
to open. And then at the last second, I'd run and I'd hop the turnstile. Before they had the big
thing, it was just a little turnstile. And I'd hop it so that I'd time it so I'd run in and beat
the fare to get on the subway in case there was a transit cop there. You know what I mean?
And then I could... Yeah, welcome to Smartless.
Welcome to Smartless.
I'm going to keep the gum very low. I'm just, I've turned it down to one.
Oh. Oh, is this, is this a suppressant?
Gum type of nicotine thing.
打开。然后在最后一秒，我会跑过去跳过检票闸机。在他们安装大闸机之前，那只是个小闸机。我会跳过去，算好时间跑进去，赶在地铁关门前上车，以防那里有交通警察。你知道我的意思吗？然后我就可以……是的，欢迎来到Smartless。欢迎来到Smartless。我会尽量少嚼口香糖。我只是，我把它调到了一档。哦。哦，这是，这是抑制剂吗？口香糖那种尼古丁产品。
It's a medicinal gum.
I just have a lot going on.
Yeah, I know.
I get it.
And he needs it today, Sean.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go easy.
这是一种药用口香糖。我最近事情太多了。是啊，我知道。我明白。而且他今天需要它，肖恩。好吧。是啊，是啊。我们轻松点。
You know what I mean?
Don't they have like,
they've got sprays now?
Can't you just like spray your mouth?
Do they really?
Yeah, they've got like a nicotine spray.
What do you mean?
You just do a spray?
你知道我的意思吗？他们现在不是有那种喷雾吗？你不能直接往嘴里喷吗？他们真的有吗？是啊，他们有那种尼古丁喷雾。你什么意思？你只是喷一下？
Yeah, and it's...
Yeah, like Benaka.
Remember Benaka?
Benaka.
Where Benaka goes?
Yeah, Benaca.
Benaca is still happening, I think.
Is it really?
对，而且它是……对，就像Benaka。还记得Benaka吗？Benaka。Benaka去哪了？对，Benaca。我想Benaca现在还在吧。真的吗？
You know what makes your breath worse?
I can't say, can we say the name?
Those tabs, those mouthwash tabs.
No, no, no, no, they do not.
You mean the little sheets?
Yeah, little tongue rubs.
They make my breath worse.
Yeah.
你知道什么会让你的口气更糟吗？我不能说，我们能说那个名字吗？那些薄片，那些漱口薄片。不，不，不，不，它们不会。你是说那些小纸片？对，那些小舌头贴。它们让我的口气更糟了。是啊。
Really?
Who said?
Yeah.
You, your mom?
No, because I use those constantly.
The little tongue wrap.
No, I know.
No, but for me, I don't know what they do.
真的吗？谁说的？是啊。你，你妈妈？不，因为我一直在用那些。那些小舌头贴。不，我知道。不，但对我来说，我不知道它们有什么用。
They make my breath worse.
Well, obviously, we know that your breath is much more about your gut.
But, you know, the thing that J.B.,
it's about your gut.
Yeah, it might be all the ground beef you have for breakfast.
Yeah, it could be, yeah.
You have spaghetti bullionies and a donut on the same plate.
You're kind of headed to a road down the road of disaster.
它们让我的口气更糟了。嗯，显然，我们知道你的口气更多是关于你的肠胃。但是，你知道，J.B.说的那件事，是关于你的肠胃。是啊，可能是因为你早餐吃的那些碎牛肉。是啊，可能是，是啊。你在同一个盘子里吃意大利肉酱面和甜甜圈。你有点走在灾难的道路上了。
But here's the thing I know about, J.B., that he hates more than just bad breath.
He hates a heavy breath.
Yes, that is true.
Right, J.B?
Something hot, warm, and, yeah.
You know what he said to me?
Like a blanket.
We were on the golf court.
但关于J.B.，我知道一件事，他讨厌的不仅仅是口臭。他讨厌沉重的呼吸。是的，那是真的。对吧，J.B？那种热的、暖的，而且，是啊。你知道他对我说了什么吗？就像一条毯子。我们在高尔夫球场上。
We were somewhere, and we were in like a golf cart together, and he goes,
He turns me with the look of utter, just...
Heavy-lid.
Disgust on his face.
And he goes, and he goes,
I can smell your laundry detergent.
But that smells good.
It does.
我们在某个地方，我们坐在一辆高尔夫球车里，他说，他转过身看着我，带着一种彻底的，只是……眼皮沉重。他脸上的厌恶。他说，他说，我能闻到你的洗衣液味。但这闻起来不错。确实。
But it was a funny thing to say.
I must have been feeling a little extra grouchy that day.
I know.
Why am I naturally grouchy?
What's wrong with me?
You're not, though.
I don't think I've...
I'm not naturally grouchy.
但这话说得很有趣。我那天一定感觉有点格外暴躁。我知道。为什么我天生就暴躁？我怎么了？你其实不是。我不觉得我……我不是天生暴躁。
grouchy i'm just not unnecessarily chipper giddy yeah i mean do you guys like well sometimes you
are and they're just like and you can tell they're not really in that good of a mood that's it's almost
like keeping you at arm's length by how happy they are hey hey how's it going go good to see you it's like
no i want to bring you in with i'm not full of shit over here right i'm i'm i'm that's so funny
how are you one of the one of the one of the many many presidents of NBC
when Will and Grace is on the air.
Have you guys heard of that show?
Yes, yes.
暴躁，我只是没有不必要地兴高采烈、轻浮。是啊，我是说你们喜欢，嗯，有时你们是这样，但你能看出他们心情其实没那么好，这几乎就像是通过他们表现出的快乐来和你保持距离。嘿，嘿，你好吗？很高兴见到你。就像，不，我想带你进来，我不是在这里装模作样，对吧，我，我，我，那太搞笑了，你好吗？在《威尔和格蕾丝》播出时，NBC的众多总裁之一。你们听说过那个节目吗？是的，是的。
Wait, Will, that's one I said that I want to try to see one of these days.
Still not ringing a bell.
I'm so sorry, it's still nothing.
Wait, so one of the presidents came in, you know, one day
and was like, something wrong with Sean to somebody?
And they're like, no, he's fine.
Like, what?
What's wrong?
等等，威尔，那是我说有一天我想试着看看的那个。还是没印象。我很抱歉，还是没想起来。等等，所以其中一位总裁有一天走进来，对某人说，肖恩有什么问题吗？他们说，不，他很好。就像，什么？怎么了？
Well, it just wasn't chipper.
And so it's like, you know, to your point,
it's like you can't, some days you just don't want to,
you just want to talk like a person.
I know.
Do you not want real today?
And that's the thing.
嗯，他只是不够兴高采烈。所以就像，你知道，说到你的观点，就像你不能，有些日子你只是不想，你只是想像个正常人一样说话。我知道。你今天不想表现得真实一点吗？我知道。这就是问题所在。
Yeah, I think that for the most part, we're pretty real with each other.
We're pretty honest about where we're at.
Yeah.
Right?
But I guess the difference is that you don't, you hope people sort of like,
they won't drag their stuff into your meeting, your time together.
Like, I'm accountable for my own stuff.
I'll put it in a little drawer.
是啊，我觉得在很大程度上，我们彼此之间都很真实。我们对自己的处境都很诚实。对吧？但我猜区别在于你不会，你希望人们某种程度上，他们不会把他们的烂事带到你的会议、你们在一起的时间里。比如，我要为我自己的事情负责。我会把它放进一个小抽屉里。
I'm not going to drag my bad mood around.
But sometimes we record a lot.
We make one of these a week.
And sometimes life happens
and you end up getting on,
and we start recording,
and you're in, you are where you are.
And there's no.
我不会到处散播我的坏心情。但有时我们录制很多。我们一周做一期。有时生活总会发生些什么，你最终上线，我们开始录制，你就在那里，你处于你的状态。而且没有。
I've, I had, God, I had somebody,
I had a thing that came up on you.
Are you ever going on that thing on threads?
It's part of, it's kind of like,
it's almost like, you know what it is, right?
It's Instagram's Twitter, basically, in a way.
Yeah, yeah.
Meta.
我，我曾经，天哪，我曾经有人，我曾经有一件事发生在你身上。你打算用那个Threads吗？它是其中的一部分，它有点像，你大概知道它是什么，对吧？它基本上就是Instagram的Twitter，某种程度上。是啊，是啊。Meta。
And something,
Somebody put my name in, and they were talking about the show,
and they were like, oh, I hate hearing him tell his story.
I didn't even, I was not looking for it.
Like, I was like, thanks, meta.
I was like, no, I didn't even, and it came up on me,
I wanted to be like, thanks a lot.
And then it was just like a litany of like, yeah,
然后某事，有人把我的名字放进去，他们在谈论这个节目，他们就像，哦，我讨厌听他讲他的故事。我甚至，我根本没在找它。就像，我当时想，谢谢你，Meta。我当时想，不，我甚至没有，它就出现在我面前，我想说，多谢了。然后它就像是一连串的，是啊，
I don't really like that guy.
You know what?
They're talking about you?
Yeah, and they're like, and I hate hearing his stories.
I don't even listen anymore, and I hate that guy.
And you couldn't stop reading.
And by the way, you can't, how can you?
And literally came up in my thing.
我真的不喜欢那个家伙。你知道吗？他们在谈论你？是啊，他们就像，而且我讨厌听他的故事。我再也不听了，而且我讨厌那个家伙。而你却停不下来阅读。顺便说一句，你不能，你怎么能？而且它确实出现在我的东西里。
And so much of it was so unbelievably mean-spirited in this way that I was like, whoa, I don't know you.
But we talk about this.
It seems like a real douchebag.
I'm like, wait a second.
What did I do?
Yeah, but that's not about you.
That's about that.
Didn't you want to chime in, Willie?
而且其中很多内容都极其刻薄，以至于我当时想，哇，我不认识你。但我们谈论过这个。他看起来像个真正的混蛋。我当时想，等一下。我做了什么？是啊，但这与你无关。那是关于那个的。你不想插话吗，威利？
Mm-hmm.
I did.
This gal said something like, he seems like, like, what did he say?
He looks like, he looks like a perpetual ex-husband or ex-husband or something like that.
I was like, hey, fucking.
I'm doing my boyfriend.
best over here. Thanks a lot.
It looks like an ex.
嗯哼。我想。这个女孩说了类似的话，他看起来像，像，他说了什么？他看起来像，他看起来像个永远的前夫或者前夫之类的。我当时想，嘿，该死。我正在做我的男朋友。尽我所能。多谢了。看起来像个前任。
You know what I mean? And it was so like,
it was so weird. And then
the mean-spirited comments after
were so rude. I was like,
I kind of wanted to go like, hey,
I'm a human, I can
hear this. You want to just like drop
your phone number and say, you know what? Just call me.
你知道我的意思吗？这太像了，太奇怪了。然后后面的刻薄评论太粗鲁了。我当时想，我有点想说，嘿，我是个人，我能听到这些。你想直接留下你的电话号码说，你知道吗？直接打给我。
Just call me. And let's talk this through.
Let's talk this through. What did I do?
It would be kind of fun. Why don't we bring
somebody on that hates us once a week?
Listen, you'd have no. Evidently.
I have no, there's no shortage of people
who would love to chime in about.
Like a book itself, a waiting list.
直接打给我。让我们谈谈这件事。让我们谈谈这件事。我做了什么？那会很有趣。为什么我们不每周请一个讨厌我们的人来呢？听着，你不会有。显然。我没有，不缺那些想插嘴的人。就像书本身，一个等待名单。
By the way, what they think I am, which is amazing.
Anyway, God, guys.
You two are two beams of sunshine.
And you know what a third beam of sunshine is?
Uh-oh.
Guys.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
顺便说一句，他们认为我是什么，这太神奇了。总之，天哪，伙计们。你们两个是两束阳光。你们知道第三束阳光是什么吗？哦哦。伙计们。是啊。哦哦。
Today we've got a guest who's a real kick.
Okay, this gal pal of ours is about as funny as they come.
as dry as burnt toast.
Time named her one of the 100
most influential people in the world.
She's been nominated for heaps of awards.
She's won plenty of them as well.
She's a producer and an actor.
今天我们请到了一位真正的惊喜嘉宾。好吧，这位我们的女性朋友非常有趣。像烧焦的吐司一样干。时代周刊将她评为全球100位最具影响力人物之一。她获得过无数奖项提名。她也赢得了不少奖项。她是一位制片人和演员。
Most important, she's one of our friends.
You guys, please welcome Miss Aubrey Plaza.
Oh, get it out here.
Oh, Brie Plaza.
It's me.
Oh, God.
Aubrey.
Oh, man.
最重要的是，她是我们的朋友之一。伙计们，请欢迎奥布瑞·普拉扎小姐。哦，让她出来。哦，布瑞·普拉扎。是我。哦，天哪。奥布瑞。哦，伙计。
I need you all.
I hate you all.
Will, do you remember when she was your girlfriend and she was also my daughter at the same time?
Yes.
What?
See, I thought you were both playing pedophiles in that.
Wait a second.
What are you talking about?
我需要你们所有人。我讨厌你们所有人。威尔，你还记得当她是你的女朋友，同时也是我的女儿的时候吗？是的。什么？看，我以为你们俩在里面演恋童癖。等一下。你在说什么？
Oh, you're the one who's been commenting online about me.
We did a digital short for, what was it?
Oh, that.
Orbits?
No, no, orbit gum.
Orbitz was a travel site.
Oh, yeah.
Orbit gum.
哦，你就是那个在网上评论我的人。我们做了一个数字短片，是为了什么？哦，那个。Orbits？不，不，Orbit口香糖。Orbitz是一个旅游网站。哦，是的。Orbit口香糖。
Orbit gum, yes, thank you.
That was a commercial?
Yeah.
It was a, yeah, it was like a...
Aubrey.
A digital ad.
You were not compensated fairly?
Orbit口香糖。Orbit口香糖，是的，谢谢。那是个广告？是啊。那是一个，是啊，它就像一个……奥布瑞。一个数字广告。你没有得到公平的报酬？
I honestly, the only thing I remembered was I thought you were both pedophiles and one of you was my dad.
Wow.
That's all I remember.
I was the dad in the pedophile glasses.
And then Will showed up, Will showed up as the too old to be dating my daughter guy.
Yeah.
And...
Oh, right.
我老实说，我唯一记得的是我以为你们俩是恋童癖，其中一个是我的爸爸。哇。这就是我记得的一切。我是戴着恋童癖眼镜的爸爸。然后威尔出现了，威尔作为那个年纪太大而不能和我女儿约会的家伙出现了。是啊。而且……哦，对了。
We were dating.
It was really funny.
And then what role did the gum play?
The gum, I put in a stick of gum
and then all of a sudden you seemed like a good choice
for my daughter, right?
Wasn't that kind of the bit?
I don't remember.
我们在约会。这真的很有趣。然后口香糖扮演了什么角色？口香糖，我放了一块口香糖，然后突然间你看起来像是我女儿的一个好选择，对吧？那不是那个梗吗？我不记得了。
Was that on television?
I don't remember the script.
It was on the computer.
You were fantastic, Aubrey.
I do remember.
I did that happen.
I don't remember anything.
Well, I remember you came to us with the idea.
那是在电视上吗？我不记得剧本了。那是在电脑上。你太棒了，奥布瑞。我确实记得。我确实发生了。我不记得任何事了。嗯，我记得你带着这个想法来找我们。
You were like, how can we get gum going again?
I think is what you said.
Oh, yeah, that sounds like me.
Gums been a card.
You've always been.
been a big advocate for gum.
I've got a friend that doesn't chew gum
because he doesn't understand
你当时说，我们怎么能让口香糖再次流行起来？我想你是这么说的。哦，是啊，那听起来像我。口香糖一直是个卡片。你一直都是。一直是口香糖的大力倡导者。我有个朋友不嚼口香糖，因为他不明白
why you chew something and not swallow it.
Like he just literally doesn't understand
the concept of it.
Is that kind of like, if you think about it,
it kind of makes sense.
I feel that way about dancing.
I don't understand why you just kind of just
move your body
为什么你嚼东西却不把它咽下去。就像他真的不理解这个概念。那是不是有点像，如果你仔细想想，它有点道理。我对跳舞也有这种感觉。我不明白为什么你只是有点移动你的身体
and the rhythm of the sound you're hearing.
It's like, why are we doing this?
That's a really tough...
No, I understand.
I'm not proud of it.
It just...
和你听到的声音的节奏。就像，我们为什么要这样做？那是一个非常艰难的……不，我明白。我不以此为荣。它只是……它只是……它只是……
It feels good.
It feels good when you connect.
It feels good when you connect a part of your body
at the same time the music is doing it.
Aubrey Plaza is on our show, guys.
What is going on?
This is insane.
Aubrey.
感觉很好。当你连接时感觉很好。当你连接身体的一部分，同时音乐也在做同样的事情时，感觉很好。奥布瑞·普拉扎在我们的节目上，伙计们。发生了什么？这太疯狂了。奥布瑞。
I want to get down.
What makes you tick?
Obviously, I know that, so I'm not going to get into that.
I know what makes you tick.
It's gum.
It's been a minute.
I went up trying to think.
我想深入了解。是什么让你动心？显然，我知道，所以我不会深入探讨那个。我知道是什么让你动心。是口香糖。是口香糖。已经有一会儿了。我一直在想。
Yeah, how are you?
I saw you last summer, I feel like.
I saw you over the summer, yeah.
Yeah.
I saw you.
Where were we?
We were out.
East as we say.
是啊，你好吗？我觉得我去年夏天见过你。我夏天见过你，是啊。是啊。我见过你。我们在哪？我们在外面。东边，正如我们所说的。
Okay.
Oh, on Long Island.
At East, yeah.
Which I'm always corrected
because I always say up.
Up East?
I'm going upstate or up, whatever.
You know who does that too?
好的。哦，在长岛。在东边，是啊。我总是被纠正，因为我总是说向上。向上东边？我要去上州或者向上，随便什么。你知道谁也这样做吗？
Who does that incessantly is polar?
Yeah.
She says up.
She says up for everything.
I think you need to be two hours
north of Manhattan to be upstate.
Up.
I don't know.
谁总是这样做是波拉？是啊。她对每件事都说向上。她说向上。我觉得你需要离曼哈顿以北两小时才能算上州。向上。我不知道。
I just don't know the, I'm learning about
the Long Island.
It goes the other way.
Well, it does go east,
but it does go kind of north too.
It is kind of angled, so you're not...
Aubrey Plaza's on the show today, everybody.
Hey, welcome, Aubrey.
我只是不知道，我正在学习关于长岛的事。它往另一个方向走。嗯，它确实往东走，但它也确实有点往北走。它有点倾斜，所以你不是……奥布瑞·普拉扎今天在节目上，大家好。嘿，欢迎，奥布瑞。
Sean, do you want to start with a little...
Sure, she knows that you know I adore you.
I run into it at the gym sometimes.
Sean, I was at your opening.
I forgot to text you.
Wait a second.
You were?
We were at the opening of the opening.
肖恩，你想从一点点开始吗……当然，她知道你知道我崇拜你。我有时在健身房碰到她。肖恩，我在你的开幕式上。我忘了给你发短信。等一下。你在吗？我们在开幕式的开幕式上。
Oh, my God, Jason wants to know about this.
Okay, walk us through.
I was there.
Wait, we were the opening when the lights went out.
Yes, I was.
Yeah.
That was really.
So we weren't at the opening.
哦，天哪，杰森想知道这件事。好吧，带我们走一遍。我在那儿。等等，我们在灯熄灭的时候开幕。是的，我在。是啊。那真的。所以我们不在开幕式上。
When were we there, Sean?
You were the day after.
The day after.
Wait, so, Aubrey.
You handled that great, by the way.
You were awesome.
Thanks.
Thank you.
我们什么时候在那儿，肖恩？你是第二天。第二天。等等，所以，奥布瑞。顺便说一句，你处理得很好。你太棒了。谢谢。谢谢你。
Really?
You went to Aubrey.
You went to the show.
Yeah.
And you enjoyed it.
And Sean was great.
And then you did not go back and say hi to him.
真的吗？你去了奥布瑞。你去了演出。你去了演出。是啊。而且你很享受。肖恩很棒。然后你没有回去跟他打招呼。
Oh, here we go.
No, I bolted the minute it was ever.
Jason, thoughts.
Okay.
I understand that.
Nobody wants to talk after.
No, they don't.
Well, Sean does.
哦，开始了。不，我一结束就跑了。杰森，想法。好吧。我明白这一点。没人想在之后说话。不，他们不想。嗯，肖恩想。
And then he wants to take a picture in the elevator.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Not me.
Jesus Christ.
The photo.
book you could make in the elevator.
嗯，肖恩想。然后他想在电梯里拍张照片。哦，不。是啊。不是我。天哪。照片。你可以在电梯里拍的书。
What's going on?
I leave while people are standing.
Scotty takes all those photos.
I know he does bless him.
Now, Aubrey, you're a theater gal.
You've done your runs at, what is it, ATC, and a couple other hot spots I've seen on the Wikipedia page.
It's so insinuating when you say it like that.
I've done.
怎么了？当人们站着的时候我离开了。斯科蒂拍了所有那些照片。我知道他拍了，保佑他。现在，奥布瑞，你是戏剧女孩。你在，是什么，ATC，还有我在维基百科页面上看到的其他几个热点做过你的演出。当你那样说的时候，这太含沙射影了。我做过。
I'm two plays.
I know.
Well, it's two more than I've done.
I'm very jealous.
But you're so you're more seasoned than I am.
So you might have a take on this.
I have heard that it is polite.
Oh, here we go.
我是两部戏。我知道。嗯，这比我做的多两部。我非常嫉妒。但你比我更有经验。所以你可能对此有看法。我听说这很有礼貌。哦，开始了。
Polite and industry norm to if you're famous and the person in the play is famous,
well, then you kind of have to go backstage and say, hi, I'm famous, you're famous and enjoyed your show.
And if you don't, then that is you're effectively saying I didn't like the piece.
No.
This is what I hear.
Well, not at the opening.
Everybody was there.
Very impolite.
礼貌和行业规范是，如果你很有名，而戏里的人也很有名，嗯，那么你得去后台说，嗨，我很有名，你很有名，很享受你的演出。如果你不这样做，那么你实际上是在说我不喜欢这部作品。不。这是我听到的。嗯，不是在开幕式上。每个人都在那儿。非常不礼貌。
Not at the opening, though, right?
The opening is it.
There's just too many people there.
It doesn't matter either way to me, honestly.
Swear to God.
I know, but I guess one...
Anna Wintour was there.
Wow.
不是在开幕式上，对吧？开幕式就是这样。那里人太多了。老实说，对我来说哪种方式都无所谓。发誓。我知道，但我猜一个……安娜·温图尔在那儿。哇。
Anna Winter, and she emailed me after.
Anna, really?
It's so nice.
I really did mean to email you.
You were great.
I really mean, I meant to.
Is it Winter or Winter?
Winter, I think.
安娜·温特，她后来给我发了邮件。安娜，真的吗？太好了。我真的打算给你发邮件。你很棒。我真的意思是，我打算。是温特还是温特？温特，我想。
Because it's T-O-U-R.
Anna Winter?
I don't know.
Aubrey, I remember the...
I said this to you before many times
and I know we've run into each other
a million times and I love you.
Is the first time I met you,
因为它是T-O-U-R。安娜·温特？我不知道。奥布瑞，我记得……我以前多次对你说过，我知道我们碰到过一百万次，我爱你。这是我第一次见到你，
which is I'm...
It was in Amy Poller's Traylor's
trailer. I was on the set of Parks and Rec, and the whole cast is in there. Amy lives in a trailer?
Yeah. And you were sitting there with Aziz and Amy and just tons of other, like people on the crew,
other people. Sounds like a pack trailer. It was. There was lots of people in there. And I said,
I looked to you and I go, what do you do on the show? Do you, are you working the crew?
You said, I'm on the show. Really? I don't remember that. That's okay. I felt so bad and I emailed you a
long email after.
也就是我……是在艾米·波勒的拖车里。我在《公园与游憩》的片场，整个剧组都在里面。艾米住在拖车里？是啊。你和阿齐兹还有艾米坐在那里，还有很多其他人，比如剧组的人，其他人。听起来像个拥挤的拖车。是的。里面有很多人。我说，我看着你，我说，你在节目里做什么？你在做剧组工作吗？你说，我在节目里。真的？我不记得了。没关系。我感觉太糟糕了，后来我给你发了一封很长的邮件。
You felt bad enough
that you wanted to bring it up
again today?
Yeah, yeah.
I thought we met at the gym.
Remember what I insulted you?
And then we met at the gym.
What did she?
你感觉糟糕到今天想再提一次？是啊，是啊。我以为我们在健身房认识的。记得我侮辱你的时候吗？然后我们在健身房认识的。她怎么了？
Did she strike you as a as a P.A?
No, you were the quietest one.
Like you didn't say anything in the trailer.
So I didn't know what was going on.
I didn't even realize I was on a television show
for like two seasons.
I do believe it.
I do believe that.
她给你的印象是助理吗？不，你是最安静的一个。就像你在拖车里什么都没说。所以我不知道发生了什么。我甚至没意识到我在电视节目里待了大约两季。我确实相信。我确实相信这一点。
Yeah.
Now, so let's go, let's stay with Parks and Rec.
Is it true?
Wiki says that you talked Mike Scher and Greg Daniels into changing the part to be a little bit more
how it became how it is how it became it wasn't originally that true untrue what do you mean like
as the show went on no no like when you went in there and you first met with them you were like
the part was written a certain way and you were like yeah but wouldn't it be funny if it was this
I don't well I don't think they had technically written it yet but I remember I went in for like a
是啊。现在，让我们继续，让我们留在《公园与游憩》。是真的吗？维基说你劝说迈克·舒尔和格雷格·丹尼尔斯把角色改得更像它后来变成的样子，它最初不是那样的，真的假的，你什么意思，比如随着节目的进行，不，不，比如当你进去第一次见到他们时，你就像，角色是那样写的，你就像，是啊，但如果它是这样会不会很有趣，我不，嗯，我不认为他们技术上已经写好了，但我记得我进去参加了一个
general meeting and I had no and I really didn't have any idea how much like weight was on that meeting
because I was I didn't have an agent. Alison Jones sets you up with that general. Allison Jones. I came out
because I was screen testing for Judd Apatow's movie. And that was huge for me because I was like plucked
out of nowhere. And then I was in LA for a week and I hadn't really been to L.A. So Allison was like,
do you mind if I just send you on a couple other meetings? And I was like, isn't your agent supposed
to do that? Sure lady. I didn't have an agent.
What a nice lady she is.
Wait, wait, Plaza, what were you...
一般会议，我没有，我真的不知道那个会议有多重要，因为我当时，我没有经纪人。艾莉森·琼斯安排你参加那个一般会议。艾莉森·琼斯。我出来是因为我在为贾德·阿帕图的电影试镜。这对我很重要，因为我就像被从虚无中拔出来一样。然后我在洛杉矶待了一周，我还没怎么去过洛杉矶。所以艾莉森说，你介意我再给你安排几个会议吗？我当时想，不是你的经纪人应该做那个吗？当然，女士。我没有经纪人。她真是个好女士。等等，等等，普拉扎，你在做什么……
I didn't have an agent.
What were you doing?
Where were you...
Where did she pluck you from and how?
UCB?
She found me at a
whore house.
Don't.
我没有经纪人。你在做什么？你在哪里……她从哪里把你拔出来的，怎么拔的？UCB？她在妓院发现了我。别。
What's the problem?
What?
Plus, it's hard out there.
No, don't say that, Plaza.
I was at Howard Beach, Queens in a
whore house.
Oh, my God.
别。有什么问题吗？什么？普拉扎，外面很难混。不，别那样说，普拉扎。我在皇后区的霍华德海滩的一家妓院。哦，天哪。
Googling.
I was...
was doing UCB shows and I was it was I don't know actually she I think it was yeah it was I was
doing UCB and and and Judd was doing like a very wide casting call because he wanted to cast an unknown
comedian to play this part and so I made it up the ranks like um like sending my videos in and
谷歌。谷歌。我当时……我当时……我当时……在做UCB的演出，我当时，我不知道其实，她我想是，是啊，我在做UCB，而且，而且，贾德在做非常广泛的选角，因为他想选一个不知名的喜剧演员来演这个角色，所以我像，像发送我的视频一样排队，然后
stuff and then I made it and then I kind of like made Allison saw my tape I somehow got a tape to her
with the scene
and then
yeah so then it was like
I made it all the levels
to the point where they were like
and now you're gonna come to LA
and do screen tests
东西，然后我做到了，然后我有点像，艾莉森看到了我的录像，我不知怎么把录像带给了她，带着那个场景，然后是啊，所以就像我通过了所有级别，直到他们说，现在你要来洛杉矶参加试镜
yeah and were you like on
did you have
like your own sketch group at UCB
or
yeah I was like
I was in a sketch group called
That's My Booze
Who were your contemporaries
是啊，你当时，你有自己的小品组在UCB吗？或者，是啊，我当时，我在一个叫“那是我的酒”的小品组。你的同时代人是谁
at that time did any
Because I remember
You were a little after
I wasn't hanging around UCB as much of them
But it was like, because I remember Aziz and those guys and Riggle
and cheered those guys back in those days when they were all there.
Yeah, like Aziz, Aziz and I were kind of in the same class,
but Aziz wasn't really doing like improv so much.
在那时，有没有，因为我记得你比我晚一点，我没怎么在UCB闲逛，但就像，因为我记得阿齐兹和那些家伙，还有里格尔和那些家伙，在他们都在那里的那些日子里。是啊，比如阿齐兹，阿齐兹和我有点在同一个班，但阿齐兹并没有真正做即兴表演。
But he would be in the sketch, you know, part of it.
And then like, you know, it was like Kroll and Manzukas and Pali
and Zach Woods and Lennon Parham and all those guys like were kind of above me.
Yeah.
like Anthony King and Kate Spencer and Joe Wengert and Chris Getherd and I could go on.
But they were kind of like seniors when I was like a freshman.
Yeah.
But I was kind of young and I was friends with them and I was like dating Joe Wengert at the time who was kind of running the school.
但他会参与小品，你知道，其中的一部分。然后就像，你知道，就像克罗尔和曼祖卡斯，还有帕利和扎克·伍兹，还有列侬·帕勒姆，所有那些家伙，某种程度上都在我之上。是啊。比如安东尼·金和凯特·斯宾塞，还有乔·温格特和克里斯·格瑟德，我还能继续说。但他们就像大四学生，而我就像大一新生。是啊。但我当时有点年轻，我和他们是朋友，我当时在和乔·温格特约会，他当时在管理学校。
Yeah.
There's a fly sign.
I know.
Now it's over here.
It's anxiety.
I have to move my arms like this.
Were you?
Were you, would you go to like Askat on Sunday nights
是啊。有一只苍蝇。我知道。现在它在这儿。是焦虑。我得像这样移动我的手臂。你是吗？你是，你会去像周日晚上的Askat吗
or at least watch or?
Yeah.
Sketch shows.
These are all sketch shows.
Yeah, I mean when I was, yeah, I would watch.
I would stand in the back.
I would see Ascad.
Did I ever meet you back then, like back before we became friends?
或者至少看，或者？是啊。小品节目。这些都是小品节目。是啊，我是说当我，是啊，我会看。我会站在后面。我会看Ascad。我以前见过你吗，比如在我们成为朋友之前？
We'd never talk about this.
No, you're kidding.
No, don't say that like that.
Don't say like that.
I'm sure we met.
I don't remember anything.
Do you miss sketch comedy?
Everyone was drunk in those days.
我们从不谈论这个。不，你在开玩笑。不，别那样说。别那样说。我肯定我们见过。我不记得任何事了。你怀念小品喜剧吗？那些日子每个人都喝醉了。
That's true.
Yeah, I love, I miss sketch comedy.
I would love to do like a...
It's still happening, you know, you guys.
It's still going on.
Where?
Yeah, no, you can find it.
By the way, where?
那是真的。是啊，我爱，我怀念小品喜剧。我很想做像一个……它还在发生，你知道，伙计们。它还在继续。在哪？是啊，不，你能找到它。顺便说一句，在哪？
Does you...
UCB's still going, yes?
Hello?
Yeah.
I don't...
Guys, anybody can answer this.
It's changed, right?
It's going.
UCB还在继续，对吧？喂？是啊。我不……伙计们，任何人都可以回答这个问题。它变了，对吧？它还在。
I think it was gone.
Like, somebody bought it or when it went or something, and now it's back.
It's a very different...
Yes, it's back.
But it's a different...
I do feel very removed from...
Because I was real, I never did even UCB in L.A.
Like, UCB, L.A. to me was like, what?
我觉得它没了。比如，有人买了它，或者当它去的时候，或者什么，现在它又回来了。它非常不同……是的，它回来了。但它是一个不同的……我确实感觉非常疏远……因为我是真实的，我甚至从未在洛杉矶做过UCB。比如，洛杉矶的UCB对我来说就像，什么？
This isn't.
Right, right.
Anything.
You were.
Only New York.
You were up on 8th Avenue.
I was in that, Chrysides' basement.
Yeah, in the Christi's basement.
这不是。对，对。任何东西。你是。只有纽约。你在第8大道上。我在那个，克里斯蒂的地下室。是啊，在克里斯蒂的地下室。
Yeah.
And we will be right back.
And now, back to the show.
All right.
So then, upright Citizens Brigade for Tracy and the rest who don't, that, that is an improv sketch place.
You go.
and you yell a sort of a prompt to the talented folks on stage.
That was Ascat.
是啊。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。好的。所以，对于特雷西和其余不知道的人来说，Upright Citizens Brigade，那是一个即兴小品场所。你去。然后对舞台上有才华的人大喊一个提示。那是Ascat。
That was the one show when they would do like a herald.
That's one type of it.
It was a place that was created by Amy Poehler
and by Matt Walsh and Matt Besser and Ian Roberts.
Right.
And they came from Chicago and they created this thing.
They were a sketch group by Partisan Brigade,
and then they created this whole theater and school and stuff
那是他们会做像哈罗德那样的节目。那是其中的一种。这是一个由艾米·波勒、马特·沃尔什、马特·贝瑟和伊恩·罗伯茨创建的地方。对。他们来自芝加哥，他们创造了这个东西。他们是一个叫“党派旅”的小品组，然后他们创造了整个剧院和学校之类的东西
in New York back in the day.
Like Second City.
And they would do those heralds.
Like you said Sunday nights, they do Ascats,
Jason, which you went to many times.
I was on a Herald team.
That's how, that was the thing.
You wanted to be on a Herald team.
在纽约，在过去的日子里。就像第二城市。他们会做那些哈罗德。就像你说的周日晚上，他们做Ascats，杰森，你去过很多次。我是哈罗德队的。那是，那是那回事。你想成为哈罗德队的一员。
That was the main.
And a Herald was that, where you have a suggestion,
and then you kind of bring everything back,
and you're kind of telling a long-form improv.
Go ahead, Jason.
But yes, so.
My explanation was a tenth of how long yours was gonna be.
No, no, mine was gonna actually be one of the rare Jason's short things.
那是主要的。而哈罗德就是那个，你有一个建议，然后你把一切都带回来，你有点在讲一个长篇即兴表演。继续，杰森。但是是的，所以。我的解释是你原本要说的十分之一长。不，不，我的实际上是罕见的杰森简短的事情之一。
I was going to get to, this is a place where you go
where there is no pre-written and pre-written dialogue.
Yes.
then Aubrey Plaza went on to start your acting career, yes, with the scripted stuff.
And how did you find that? How did you find that transition where you have to now, instead of making
up what you say, follow what is already pre-written, the typical actor journey?
I mean, I always, that's what I, I love movies. I'm like a movie person, real. I mean, I'm a, I love comedy and improv, but I,
for me it was always like
我正要说，这是一个你去的地方，那里没有预先写好的对话。是的。然后奥布瑞·普拉扎继续开始你的演艺生涯，是的，用剧本的东西。你觉得怎么样？你觉得那个过渡怎么样，你现在必须，而不是编造你说的话，遵循已经预先写好的东西，典型的演员旅程？我是说，我总是，这就是我，我爱电影。我就像一个电影人，真实的。我是说，我爱喜剧和即兴表演，但我，对我来说，它总是像
how do I get to the
movies part
like that was always
and what was it what was the first
what was the first stuff were you doing
some of that scripted stuff while you were
while you were also
playing around over there
我怎么才能进入电影部分，那总是，那是什么，那是什么，第一件事是什么，你在做那些剧本的东西吗，当你也在那边玩的时候
I mean I tried I was like you know
auditioning for whatever I could
when I was doing comedy stuff but
but it really didn't start to you came out here
at L.A.?
Yeah I mean I really truly did have like a big
break moment like the
with Parks and Rec.
我是说我试过，我当时，你知道，试镜任何我能试镜的东西，当我做喜剧的时候，但它真的没有开始，直到你来到洛杉矶？是啊，我是说我确实有一个很大的突破时刻，比如《公园与游憩》。
Funny people.
Funny people was technically first.
Oh, funny people.
You know, I've told the story.
So then you got that Judd's screen test.
You got it.
Yeah, so basically, like, I went out to L.A. for one week, and I got, I booked funny people, Parks and Rec and Scott Pilgrim versus the world in one week.
Boom.
《滑稽人物》。《滑稽人物》技术上是第一个。哦，《滑稽人物》。你知道，我讲过这个故事。所以你得到了那个贾德的试镜。你得到了它。是啊，所以基本上，我去了洛杉矶一周，我得到了，我预订了《滑稽人物》、《公园与游憩》和《歪小子斯科特对抗全世界》，在一周内。砰。
Oh, my God.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Bada bang.
And it was like, what?
Did Allison cast Scott Bildham, too?
What?
Did Allison Cascott Pilgrim too?
哦，天哪。哇。那太疯狂了。巴达砰。而且就像，什么？艾莉森也选了《斯科特·比尔德姆》？什么？艾莉森也选了《斯科特·比尔德姆》？
Yeah, she sent me on all those meetings.
And the Parks and Rec meeting, not to backtrack,
was like they hadn't written the script yet.
And Mike and Scher and Greg Daniels were in the room.
And I just went into Mike's office.
And I was just having a casual conversation with him.
And he just kind of said like, you know what else you booked that week?
Michael Sarah.
是啊，她让我参加了所有那些会议。而《公园与游憩》的会议，不是要回溯，就像他们还没写剧本。迈克·舒尔和格雷格·丹尼尔斯在房间里。我只是走进迈克的办公室。我只是在和他进行随意的谈话。他只是有点说，你知道你那周还预订了什么吗？迈克尔·塞拉。
Let's talk about Michael Sarah.
Wait, what?
She's got pilgrim, you mean?
Wait, but didn't she guys, you guys dated for a while, right?
Didn't you guys date for a while, right?
You guys date for a while?
Yeah.
But this was news to me when I was reading Wikipedia this morning.
让我们谈谈迈克尔·塞拉。等等，什么？你是说《斯科特·比尔德姆》？等等，但你们不是，伙计们，你们约会了一段时间，对吧？你们不是约会了一段时间，对吧？你们约会了一段时间？是啊。但这对我来说是新闻，当我今天早上读维基百科的时候。
Well, he's our baby writing.
He was my son.
And you were my daughter at one point.
Sure, sure, sure.
You know, so it was like, oh, well, that's kind of like your dad's.
Booked and bagged him, real good.
Booked and bagged.
Well, we found our first cut.
嗯，他是我们的宝贝写作。他是我的儿子。而你曾经是我的女儿。当然，当然，当然。你知道，所以就像，哦，好吧，那有点像你爸爸的。预订并装袋，真的很好。预订并装袋。嗯，我们找到了我们的第一个剪辑。
There we go.
We found our first thing that we went.
No, I'm kidding.
But Wiki said it was 18 months.
That's a significant relationship.
That's a good thing, right?
Wow.
That was a long time ago.
我们走吧。我们找到了我们去的第一件事。不，我在开玩笑。但维基说那是18个月。那是一段重要的关系。那是一件好事，对吧？哇。那是很久以前的事了。
We were going to get married for a second.
And we're still very good friends.
I love him so much.
We almost got married.
We drove across the country together eating a bag of edibles.
Edibles.
Crums of edibles.
And we drove to Vegas with the plan to get married and then get divorced right away
我们曾经打算结婚一秒钟。我们仍然是很好的朋友。我非常爱他。我们差点结婚。我们开车横穿全国，吃了一袋大麻食品。大麻食品。大麻食品的碎屑。我们开车去拉斯维加斯，计划结婚，然后马上离婚
so we could call each other our ex-wife and ex-husband forever because we thought that
would be a really good bit.
That's a great bit.
Yeah, that is a good bit.
But then I think it was a combination of being too high and paranoid.
And then at that time, he was just very, very famous at that time.
He, like, really, if you remember, like, when Nick and Nora and all that stuff came out,
he was super bad.
这样我们就可以永远称对方为前妻和前夫，因为我们认为那会是一个非常好的梗。那是个很棒的梗。是啊，那是个好梗。但后来我想那是太高了和偏执的结合。而且在那个时候，他当时非常，非常有名。他，就像，真的，如果你记得，比如当《尼克和诺拉》和所有那些东西出来的时候，他超级糟糕。
He was so recognizable that, like, we won.
I feel like we got in line at the county office or something.
And then everyone started running, and we ran.
So that's kind of all I remember what happened
Wow, the fame saved you
Yeah
He was too
The rare case
他太容易被认出来了，以至于，我们赢了。我觉得我们在县办公室排队或者什么。然后每个人都开始跑，我们也跑了。所以这就是我记得发生的一切。哇，名声救了你。是啊，他太罕见了。
I'm pretty sure that's how it went down
Yeah, we bailed
But
Now what
What
I'm gonna stay
I'm gonna stay in
Again what the great great
我很确定事情就是这样发生的。是啊，我们保释了。但现在，什么，我要留下来，我要留下来，再次，什么伟大的，伟大的
Wikipedia has laid out for me here
Going in chronological order
And I'm sorry if this is a
We don't have to talk about this if you don't want to
but it is, I think you've talked about it before.
There was, at that time, you had a rare stroke that a young person?
Why rare for a young person?
I did.
维基百科为我列出的这里。按时间顺序。我很抱歉，如果这是一个，我们不必谈论这个，如果你不想，但它是，我想你以前谈过。那时，你有一个罕见的中风，一个年轻人？为什么对年轻人来说罕见？我有。
I had one at, I was 20, so it was before them.
But it was when I was in New York, yeah.
I was doing, yeah, I was doing UCB comedy stuff.
I was in college.
You've got Sean's attention.
Sean, Sean's running from a stroke every day.
Oh, you didn't know?
Yeah.
我有一个，我20岁，所以是在他们之前。但那是我在纽约的时候，是啊。我在做，是啊，我在做UCB喜剧。我在上大学。你引起了肖恩的注意。肖恩，肖恩每天都在从中风中逃跑。哦，你不知道？是啊。
No, I didn't know that.
Tell me, wait, how did you, how did it, like, how did it happen?
And what did you feel?
It happened like truly in mid-sentence out of nowhere.
It's a horrifying story.
You just start flooring your words?
I had taken my sister to a Hillary Duff concert the night before.
不，我不知道。告诉我，等等，你是怎么，它是怎么，比如，它是怎么发生的？你感觉到了什么？它发生得就像真的在半句话中，凭空出现。这是一个可怕的故事。你只是开始含糊不清地说你的话？这是一个可怕的故事。前一天晚上我带我妹妹去看了希拉里·达夫的演唱会。
Sure.
And you know how that goes.
And then I was having lunch in Queens.
I took the subway.
I was feeling normal.
I had my coat on still.
I walked into my friend's apartment in Astoria to have lunch.
them and I was telling them about the Hillary Duff concert and I said like Hillary Duff and then I stroked out and I kind of the first thing that happened was like my right arm was numb and I looked down and I was confused. I wasn't slurring but I was looking at my arm like that's not my arm it wasn't even numb it was just not connected to my body and then wow then I kind of blacked out for like a second and then I came to could move my arms but I could
当然。你知道那是怎么回事。然后我在皇后区吃午饭。我坐了地铁。我感觉很正常。我身上还穿着外套。我走进我朋友在阿斯托里亚的公寓吃午饭。他们，我正在告诉他们关于希拉里·达夫的演唱会，我说，像希拉里·达夫，然后我中风了，我有点，发生的第一件事是我的右臂麻木了，我往下看，我很困惑。我没有含糊不清，但我看着我的手臂，就像那不是我的手臂，它甚至不麻木，它只是没有连接到我的身体，然后哇，然后我有点昏迷了一秒钟，然后我恢复了，能移动我的手臂，但我能
speak because the blood clot was in my language center.
Oh my gosh.
So it was like not even slurring, it was just like not talking.
Not talking.
But I could understand everything that was happening.
And how does somebody at 20 years old get a blood clot or get a heart attack or whatever or stroke?
I don't know. It's a, honestly, it's a mystery.
I think it was birth control or the tricyclin.
说话，因为血块在我的语言中心。哦，天哪。所以它就像甚至没有含糊不清，它只是像不说话。不说话。但我能理解正在发生的一切。一个20岁的人怎么会得血块或心脏病或什么的或中风？我不知道。这是一个，老实说，这是一个谜。我想是避孕药或三环素。
That was the only thing I was putting in my body.
Like I wasn't on drugs or, you know, doing anything weird.
weird so it was a real fluke like and even to this day like I still have to you know whenever I go
the doctors I have to fill out like my history and right I've seen I've seen top neurologists
I've been tested for you know all the blood disorders and clotting disorders and everything and it's
just like I really think it it must have been birth control because they have that on the label so
then what did they were you were you fine right then or did they take you to
the hospital like how do they fix i was not fine because i wasn't i wasn't i wasn't talking and so
那是唯一我放进我身体的东西。就像我没有吸毒或，你知道，做任何奇怪的事情。奇怪，所以这是一个真正的侥幸，即使到今天，我仍然必须，你知道，每当我去看医生，我必须填写我的病史，对，我见过，我见过顶级神经科医生，我被测试过，你知道，所有的血液疾病和凝血障碍等等，它只是，我真的认为它一定是避孕药，因为他们在标签上有那个，所以他们做了什么，你当时很好，还是他们带你去医院，他们怎么修复，我当时不好，因为我没有，我没有，我没有说话，所以
my friends were like first of course thought i was doing a bit and they were like stop it um and then
they realized like something's wrong and so the paramedics came and sorry are you lucid at this
point like are you aware like this is happening to you like it's a really weird thing when you have
a stroke i've read books about it um and it's it's across the board really similar experience that
people have, you know what's happening. And your brain, there's, it really makes you understand that
there's your brain and then there's something else going on, which is very profound to think about,
because I was, whatever that other thing is, was watching my brain malfunction. And so I was,
me was aware that my brain wasn't working right. So it's this really fucked up thing where you're
我的朋友们就像，首先当然以为我在演戏，他们就像，停下，嗯，然后他们意识到，像有什么不对劲，所以医护人员来了，抱歉，你在这个时候清醒吗，比如你意识到，这正在发生在你身上，就像这是一个非常奇怪的事情，当你中风时，我读过关于它的书，嗯，而且它在各方面都非常相似，人们有这种经历，你知道正在发生什么。你的大脑，有，它真的让你明白有你的大脑，然后还有其他事情正在发生，这思考起来非常深刻，因为我当时，无论那个其他东西是什么，都在看着我的大脑故障。所以我当时，我意识到我的大脑工作不正常。所以这是一个非常糟糕的事情，你
like, wait a minute. Like my consciousness is,
operating on another level.
And so people would talk to me
and I would know how to respond to them.
I would know the answer,
but I could not get it through the pathways
of my brain out of my mouth.
Wow.
就像，等一下。就像我的意识是，在另一个层面上运作。所以人们会跟我说话，我会知道如何回应他们。我会知道答案，但我无法通过大脑的路径把它从嘴里说出来。哇。
So frightening.
Did you, after that experience,
did it give you a sort of a different sense
on, I don't know how to say, like spirituality?
Did you feel like a, do you have?
Yeah.
As you said, because you're sort of conscious
哇。太可怕了。在那次经历之后，它给了你一种不同的感觉，关于，我不知道怎么说，比如灵性？你觉得像一个，你有吗？是啊。正如你所说，因为你某种程度上是有意识的
or whatever this other thing that's operating,
Yeah, did it change your view of like...
Did it change the way that you look at stuff
and look at spirituality and stuff like that?
Yeah, 100, like 100 million percent.
Like I definitely...
Honda P.
Hondo P just felt like, all right, well, if that's true,
或者无论这个其他正在运作的东西是什么，是啊，它改变了你对比如……它改变了你看待事物和看待灵性之类的方式吗？是啊，100，像1亿%。就像我肯定……本田P，本田P只是觉得，好吧，嗯，如果那是真的，
then like something bigger is...
Something bigger is going...
I am very fascinated with that.
Yeah, I am too now.
Well, so when I say, I guess it did change,
but were you...
I don't know.
Sounds like such a sort of sweeping quote.
那么像更大的东西是……更大的东西正在……我对那个非常着迷。是啊，我现在也是。嗯，所以当我这么说时，我想它确实改变了，但你当时……我不知道。听起来像是一个非常笼统的引用。
Were you a spiritual person before?
But did you have, what were your thoughts on that kind of stuff before?
Well, I grew up really, I grew up Catholic.
I grew up very Catholic.
I was, I went to all girls, you know,
I went to all girls Catholic school my whole life.
And so, you know, my spirituality was like very wrapped up in like saints and God and Jesus and, you know,
and things like that.
你以前是个有灵性的人吗？你以前对这类事情有什么看法？嗯，我成长过程中，我是在天主教环境下长大的。我成长得非常天主教。我，我这辈子一直都在上全女生的天主教学校。所以，你知道，我的灵性很大程度上与圣徒、上帝、耶稣以及诸如此类的事情紧密相连。
But, but I would say that I've always, I feel like I've always had been.
a spiritual person.
You know, now I've shifted
into more the dark arts, you know.
Oh.
Paganism.
And, yeah.
Okay.
但是，但我会说我一直，我觉得我一直都是一个有灵性的人。你知道，现在我已经转向了更多的黑魔法，你知道。哦。异教。是的。好的。
You're like, by the way, can I get a sample
of your guys' blood after this?
Then she goes,
don't bother, I've already got it.
I've already got it.
It's my schick.
The whole witch thing.
But no, I am.
你就像是，顺便问一下，我能在之后拿你们的血样吗？然后她说，别费心了，我已经拿到了。我已经拿到了。这是我的招牌。整个女巫的事情。但不是，我是。
And I think I did really stop,
at least for some time,
for some time, like,
sweating the small stuff a little bit.
Like I felt,
I did have a, I did really feel like, wow, A, the trauma of something like that happening so out of nowhere changes the way your brain is because you're like, well, okay, if that can happen like that, then the fuck else can happen and what's the point of, you know.
Right, you're not walking around thinking like that can happen like today, are you?
Not anymore, but I was after that. I was very like PTSD.
而且我觉得我确实停下来了，至少有一段时间，有一段时间，不再为小事烦恼了。就像我感觉，我确实有一种，我真的觉得，哇，A，那种突如其来的创伤改变了你的大脑运作方式，因为你会想，好吧，如果那种事能那样发生，那还能发生什么鬼事，而且有什么意义呢，你知道。对，你不会走在路上想着那种事今天可能会发生，对吧？不再会了，但在那之后我会。我当时非常像创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。
Did it make you less cynical, do you think?
I think, yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
I feel like I would that...
Contrary to popular.
That might straighten you out, Will.
No, I don't think that you're cynical at all.
I don't.
你觉得这让你变得不那么愤世嫉俗了吗？我想，是的，我想是的。是的。我觉得我会……与大众观点相反。那可能会让你改过自新，威尔。不，我不觉得你愤世嫉俗。我不觉得。
So, but you would never take birth control
whatever that thing is now, right?
I probably wouldn't.
I mean, that was the one...
For Aubrey.
But if that was the one thing
that you could kind of point to...
Well...
所以，但你现在绝对不会再服用避孕药之类的东西了，对吧？我可能不会。我的意思是，那是唯一……为了奥布里。但如果那是你可以指出的唯一一件事……嗯……
Um...
There's a baby inside of me.
What's that?
Hold.
Wait, wait.
Wait, what did you say?
嗯……我肚子里有个宝宝。什么？等等。等等。等等，等等。等等，你说什么？
What did you say?
No, I said there is a baby inside of me right now.
Is that a true story?
Is that true?
Yeah, that's true.
What?
Wait, serious, that's amazing.
That's so good.
你说什么？不，我说我现在肚子里有个宝宝。这是真的吗？是真的吗？是的，是真的。什么？等等，认真的吗，太棒了。那太好了。
Oh, thanks.
That's very exciting.
I know it's shocking, isn't it?
That's really cool.
Is this baby number one?
Yes.
That's right.
哦，谢谢。那太令人兴奋了。我知道这很令人震惊，不是吗？那真的很酷。那真的很酷。这是第一个宝宝吗？是的。没错。
Number one.
How exciting, Aubrey.
I'll just say this.
I went, today was a big day.
I went to the doctors today.
And my dog is also one to the doctors.
Also pregnant?
My dog's getting a scan right now.
第一个。多令人兴奋啊，奥布里。我只想说，我去了，今天是个大日子。我今天去了医生那里。我的狗也去了医生那里。也怀孕了？我的狗现在正在做扫描。
I got a scan earlier.
I'm not kidding.
Frankie's getting an ultrasound on her stomach.
She'll be back.
When is she back?
Two o'clock, we'll find out.
I think she's okay.
She had to get an ultrasound on her stomach.
我早些时候做了扫描。我没开玩笑。弗兰基正在做腹部超声波检查。她会回来的。她什么时候回来？两点，我们会知道结果。我想她没事。她必须做腹部超声波检查。
And then I got an ultrasound on my stomach
and there is a baby in there.
That's amazing.
That's so exciting.
I'm so excited.
I'm happy for you.
Yeah.
And it already has like a cloak and a little hat.
然后我做了腹部超声波检查，里面有个宝宝。那太棒了。那太令人兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我为你感到高兴。是的。而且它已经像是有了一件斗篷和一顶小帽子。
No.
I think it's going to come out.
But let me ask you something.
If the ultrasound was,
if you got the ultrasound out at the vet,
I would recommend that you go.
No, no, no, Jason.
No, we did, I did accidentally go to the vet first,
不。我想它会出来的。但让我问你一件事。如果超声波是在兽医那里做的，我会建议你去。不，不，不，杰森。不，我们确实，我确实不小心先去了兽医那里，
but then that's why I was late.
Aubrey, I'm so happy for you.
I just think, you know that.
I just think that you're such a great person.
And I'm just loving you so much.
I'm really, really, really happy for you.
Yep.
但那就是我迟到的原因。奥布里，我真为你感到高兴。我只是觉得，你知道的。我只是觉得你是一个非常好的人。我真的很爱你。我真的，真的，真的为你感到高兴。是的。我真的，真的，真的为你感到高兴。
awesome.
You've always got,
you're so funny
and you're so,
just such a great person.
Yeah, aren't you excited
about being a mom?
I mean,
太棒了。你一直都，你太有趣了，你只是，真是个好人。是的，你不为成为妈妈感到兴奋吗？我的意思是，
you're going to be great.
I am, yeah.
I've always wanted,
I've always wanted, I've always wanted to see
what that's all about, you know.
It just seems so interesting.
That whole thing.
Oh, how incredible.
你会成为一个好妈妈的。我是，是的。我一直想，我一直想，我一直想看看那到底是怎么回事，你知道。这看起来太有趣了。整个事情。哦，太不可思议了。
Thank you so much for sharing it with us.
Congratulations.
It's all great news.
It's very, very thrilling.
Aubrey, you've been so busy, too.
I mean, you...
Are you working right now?
First of all, I was realizing last year,
非常感谢你与我们分享。恭喜。这都是好消息。这非常，非常令人激动。奥布里，你也一直很忙。我的意思是，你……你现在在工作吗？首先，我去年意识到，
I want to talk about this because I don't think it got enough.
And you and I talked about it last year.
I watched your movie, Emily, the Criminal.
And I know it's long gone and whatever.
I thought that was such a great movie.
Your performance in that was so, so good, Plaza.
I mean, really, I don't know if you guys saw it.
What an awesome movie and what a great performance.
我想谈谈这个，因为我觉得它没有得到足够的关注。你和我去年谈过。我看了你的电影《罪犯艾米丽》。我知道它已经过去很久了，不管怎样。我觉得那是一部很棒的电影。你在那里的表演太，太好了，普拉扎。我的意思是，真的，我不知道你们有没有看。多么棒的电影，多么精彩的表演。
All I know is every time I see you in any...
I didn't see that particular one,
but every time I see you in anything,
I'm always stunned by how...
how confident you are in being still.
I just find it is it's such a, it's so,
it's so, I don't know,
it's not attractive or infectious is not the word I'm looking for.
我只知道每次我在任何……我没看过那一部，但每次我在任何东西里看到你，我总是被你……你在保持静止时是多么自信所震撼。我只是觉得这，这太，这太，我不知道，这不是吸引人或感染力，这不是我在寻找的词。
As an audience member,
I'm just, I'm drawn in and I can't stop watching somebody
who's so comfortable not helping me as an audience member
knowing what's going on inside your head.
You know, like I lean forward.
And being able to do that, J.B., like in a,
in a drama where you have to be very sort of vulnerable,
very real, and then being able to,
作为观众，我只是，我被吸引住了，我无法停止观看一个如此舒适地不让我作为观众知道你脑子里在想什么的人。你知道，就像我身体前倾。而且能够做到这一点，J.B.，就像在一部戏剧中，你必须非常脆弱，非常真实，然后能够，
and also do it in comedy, you have so,
you have such facility with all of it,
and I think it's really impressive.
Yeah, so subtle, it's really...
I just, I hope people go back and re-watch that
and then continue to watch the newer stuff,
but I wanted to say that, because you know how much I love that movie.
Thank you for saying that. I love that movie.
并且也能在喜剧中做到这一点，你对这一切都有如此的天赋，我觉得这真的很令人印象深刻。是的，如此微妙，这真的……我只是，我希望人们回去重看那部电影，然后继续看新的作品，但我只是想说，因为你知道我有多喜欢那部电影。谢谢你这么说。我喜欢那部电影。
That was such a baby of mine, that film.
I'm so proud of it.
Like, I just want...
The script was so good,
and I was like, as a producer,
you know, just like, if we could just, it really taught me that it is always the fucking script.
It's like, it is this fucking script.
I'm like, if we shoot the script, exactly how it's written, the movie is going to be good.
那部电影就像我的孩子一样。我为它感到骄傲。就像，我只是想……剧本太好了，我当时想，作为制片人，你知道，就像，如果我们能，它真的教会了我，永远都是该死的剧本。就像，就是这个该死的剧本。我想，如果我们按照剧本写的去拍，电影就会很好。
And it was, we didn't compromise.
And that was what I was so proud of.
We really didn't compromise the script.
And then the movie turned out great.
And obviously so many other things have to happen to make, you know, to make that happen.
But it taught me that.
Where did your, where did your, where did your taste for,
what your particular style, where did that come from?
确实如此，我们没有妥协。这就是我感到如此自豪的原因。我们真的没有在剧本上妥协。然后电影结果很棒。显然还有很多其他事情必须发生才能，你知道，才能实现这一点。但它教会了我这一点。你的，你的，你的品味，你的独特风格，是从哪里来的？
Was one of your parents particularly dry?
Was there an actor or an actress that you really admired coming up?
I don't know.
I don't even think, I mean, I don't even know.
It's hard for me to really have perspective on that at all
because I feel like the deadpan.
Maybe I've, maybe that's how I wasn't really always,
你的父母中有一位特别冷幽默吗？在你成长过程中，有没有你真正钦佩的男演员或女演员？我不知道。我不知道。我甚至不认为，我的意思是，我甚至不知道。对我来说，很难真正对此有任何看法，因为我觉得那种冷面笑匠。也许我，也许这就是我并不总是，
like that growing like that wasn't like really my thing but then i think that the things that i got
cast in first like character wise uh for me like i'm not saying like oh i'm a method actor but like
i do think that like i capitalized on this persona early on because the funny people role was really
based on you know and and i know it wasn't officially said but i'm pretty sure that it was based on jean
Garofalo and so and I kind of knew that and I studied her and her stand-up.
Right. Also incredibly dry and hilarious. Right and she was like, you know, she's such a hero of
mine like loved watching her and then the Parks and Rec character was also kind of born out of
that same. There was a lot of stuff that there was a zone there that I was like, I couldn't do that.
像那样成长，那并不是我真正擅长的，但后来我想，我最初被选中的角色，在性格方面，呃，对我来说，就像，我不是说，哦，我是方法派演员，但我确实认为，我早期利用了这种人设，因为《滑稽人物》的角色确实是基于，你知道，而且我知道这不是官方说的，但我很确定它是基于珍·加罗法洛，所以，我有点知道这一点，我研究了她和她的单口喜剧。对。也极其冷幽默且搞笑。对，她就像，你知道，她是我的偶像，我喜欢看她，然后《公园与游憩》的角色也某种程度上诞生于此。那里有一个区域，我当时想，我做不到。
Are you ever, are you ever, do you ever allow yourself to think somewhat strategically about well maybe I
should play a part that shows that I can do
all the other side of the
spectrum as well. I mean, is that,
do you, are you one of those actors that
considers that kind of thing?
I mean, I think
I think when I was on parks
你有没有，你有没有，你有没有允许自己战略性地思考，也许我应该扮演一个角色，展示我也能做到光谱的另一面。我的意思是，你是那种会考虑这类事情的演员吗？我的意思是，我想我想当我在《公园》时，
definitely because I was always like,
get me out of this zone.
I got to show people what I can do.
You know, so I was always
like, you know, dirty grandpa
was an example where I was like, get me that
fucking part. Like, that has nothing
to do with it.
绝对是因为我总是想，让我离开这个区域。我得向人们展示我能做什么。你知道，所以我总是说，你知道，《下流祖父》就是一个例子，我当时说，给我那个该死的角色。就像，那与此无关。
but now I'm more just like
I just want to be
I just honestly just want to be in something good
I don't even care it's not even about
oh I want to blow everyone away
with my performance but I want to be in
movies that people
remember watch more than once
但现在我更多的是，我只是想，我真的只是想参与一些好的作品，我甚至不在乎，这甚至不是关于，哦，我想用我的表演让所有人惊叹，但我想要参与人们会记住、会看不止一次的电影，
that don't just
float away into the ether
that is like that never happened
and the producing effort is
in that direction
yeah is it to sort of like
start to like cook your
own food, right?
而不是仅仅消失在以太中，就像从未发生过一样，制片工作就是朝着这个方向。是的，是为了开始像自己做饭一样，对吧？
And as opposed to just react to the phone ringing.
Yeah, I mean, I'm still an actor.
Like, I'm still like, why is no one calling me?
Like, yeah.
Where am I?
I'm not hard to believe.
Right, right, right.
Right, right.
而不是仅仅对电话铃声做出反应。是的，我的意思是，我仍然是一名演员。就像，我仍然会想，为什么没人给我打电话？就像，是的。我在哪？我不难相信。对，对，对。对，对。
No, no, no, no, I get a lot of, I get a lot of, I'm in a very good, I'm very
grateful for my, you know, position, whatever.
I get off from things, of course.
But like, I still have that, like, actor thing where I'm like, yeah.
But producing, I think was.
at first very much about like all right well if i'm not going to get you know offered parts that
i really want then i'll just fucking do it myself um right but now it's more but then i really
but i really i went to film school you know i studied film at n yu i studied directing and
不，不，不，不，我得到很多，我得到很多，我处于一个非常好的，我非常感激我的，你知道，位置，不管怎样。我当然会得到一些东西。但就像，我仍然有那种，就像，演员的毛病，我会想，是的。但制片，我想是。起初非常像是，好吧，如果我没有得到，你知道，我真正想要的角色的邀约，那我就自己做。嗯，对，但现在更多的是，但我真的，但我真的，我去了电影学校，你知道，我在纽约大学学习电影，我学习导演和
producing and i i truly love the craft of filmmaking like i really love movies so like it all is it's
also has nothing to do with acting and it's really about just start you know making something from the
very beginning to the very end and seeing it through and being like, you know, how can I make a
great film? Did you have a favorite movie this year? The Oscars was like a month ago.
You know, did you love any of those?
This year was really tough for me. I just could not get into any of it. I will say, and I don't
understand why Eddington just got, why everyone's pretending that movie didn't happen.
I love that movie. That movie is fucking great and I don't want to hear it.
制片，我真的热爱电影制作的工艺，就像我真的热爱电影，所以这一切，它也与表演无关，它真的只是关于开始，你知道，从头到尾制作一些东西，并坚持到底，然后想，你知道，我怎样才能拍出一部伟大的电影？你今年有最喜欢的电影吗？奥斯卡是一个月前的事了。你知道，你喜欢其中的任何一部吗？今年对我来说真的很难。我就是无法进入任何一部。我会说，我不明白为什么《埃丁顿》只是被，为什么每个人都在假装那部电影没发生过。我喜欢那部电影。那部电影太棒了，我不想听。
Yeah.
That movie's great.
Incredible.
I don't know what everyone's...
I love that movie too.
What the hell was that?
Amazing. Where did that go?
I don't understand.
是的。那部电影很棒。不可思议。我不知道大家都在……我也喜欢那部电影。那到底是什么？太棒了。那去哪了？我不明白。
Apparently like it wasn't embraced at Cannes where it premiered.
Whatever.
No divisive filmmakers.
Em-gasser.
Yeah, that was a stunning movie.
I thought that was incredible.
In certain regard this, motherfucker.
I'm sitting on a really stupid pun that it's too far removed from what we were talking about.
显然它在戛纳首映时没有受到欢迎。不管怎样。不，有争议的电影制作人。艾姆-加瑟。是的，那是一部令人惊叹的电影。我觉得那太不可思议了。在某些方面，这个，混蛋。我正坐着一个非常愚蠢的双关语，它离我们谈论的话题太远了。
Just go for it now
No, but it's just like OCD now
I just want to get it out
Okay
And you're saying you're saying
You've stopped the parts
So while we're stopped
Oh you were saying the parts are coming
现在就说出来吧。不，但这就像强迫症一样，我现在只想把它说出来。好的。你说你，你说你，你停止了那些角色。所以当我们停止时，哦，你说角色正在到来，
And then you know
The parts that you want
And I go maybe you could do
Some parts for fun
You know and they
You could call them
Parts for recreation
You know what I mean
然后你知道，你想要的角色。我说也许你可以做一些为了好玩的角色。你知道，你可以称它们为娱乐角色。你知道我的意思吗？
And I'm just saying
What I'm saying is
Had I said that back then
I wouldn't have had to stop
And this is why people
hate me on the show
Well I get it
We'll trim it.
我只是说，我想说的是，如果我当时那样说了，我就不必停止了。这就是为什么人们在节目中讨厌我。好吧，我明白了。我们会修剪它的。
We'll tighten it all up.
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
All right.
Well, I want to, is there, Delaware, right?
That's where we started.
This is where the dream.
我们会把它全部收紧。是的。我们马上回来。回到节目。好的。好吧，我想，有没有，特拉华州，对吧？那是我们开始的地方。这就是梦想所在。
What a question, please.
That's what I was going to ask too.
But I was going to ask, like, because I've only known you as an adult, I'm fascinated with
who you were as a child and were you this dry and funny and witty?
And were your friends, did you have like a circle of friends that should,
shared your sense of humor or were you like i i mean i definitely i was definitely a shy
kid up until when i discovered theater like very classically like you know i i went to like the
well meitand drama league which is the the community theater i i learned at and when i was like
什么问题，请。那也是我要问的。但我本来想问，因为我只认识成年的你，我对你小时候的样子很着迷，你当时也这么冷幽默、有趣和机智吗？你的朋友们，你有没有一个分享你幽默感的朋友圈，或者你就像，我，我的意思是，我绝对，我绝对是一个害羞的孩子，直到我发现戏剧，就像非常经典地，你知道，我去了，嗯，梅特兰戏剧联盟，也就是我学习的社区剧院，当我大约
11 and i started to see oh people are pretending to be other people this sounds really fun and so then
all of a sudden i kind of understood that that was a
outlet for me and then I and then I think I came out of my shell more and then by the time I was like
you know in middle school or whatever I was like funny and then the and then your summer program at
NYU that was sort of like okay there's a bridge has been built to uh to the to the big city and that's
kind of how that is that how that role worked well I think like I had a friend who's a comedian
Neil Casey who you probably know well um writer really funny comedian you know you know Neil
I think I do a new deal yeah
11岁时，我开始看到，哦，人们在假装成其他人，这听起来很有趣，所以突然间我明白那对我来说是一个出口，然后我，然后我想我更多地走出了我的壳，然后到我上初中或什么的，我就变得有趣了，然后，你在纽约大学的暑期项目，那就像是，好吧，一座桥梁已经建成，通往大城市，这就是那个角色运作的方式吗？嗯，我想就像我有一个朋友是喜剧演员尼尔·凯西，你可能很了解，嗯，作家，非常有趣的喜剧演员，你知道，你知道尼尔，我想我认识尼尔，是的，
an old school UCB guy, but he,
him and I grew up together. He was a little
bit older than me, but he went to the
old boys brother school. He introduced me
to John Waters' movies and
to UCB, the
The Upbrates Interrogate Show
on those on television. And kids
一个老派的UCB成员，但他，他和我在成长过程中认识。他比我大一点，但他去了老男孩兄弟学校。他向我介绍了约翰·沃特斯的电影和UCB，电视上的《Upright Citizens Brigade》节目。还有《Kids
in the hall and Mr. Show, and we got
into like stuff like that
as teenagers, like young
teenagers. And then I started to really
become like a comedy freak
and then develop
like my love for films and movies.
Who were your comedy idol, sorry, who were your...
in the Hall》和《Mr. Show》，我们十几岁时就开始接触这类东西，就像年轻的青少年。然后我开始真正成为一个喜剧怪胎，然后发展了我对电影和影片的热爱。谁是你的喜剧偶像，抱歉，谁是你的……
Did you have?
I mean, Garofalo.
I mean, I always blank.
I always like black out when people ask me.
I know, I don't forget.
Was there any other, like, was there any other occupation or industry or career that was that was battling your growing dream for this to be an actor?
Like, was there any other thing that you were thinking about maybe going to college to study?
No.
你有吗？我的意思是，加罗法洛。我的意思是，我总是空白。当人们问我时，我总是会断片。我知道，我没忘。有没有其他，就像，有没有其他职业或行业或事业在与你成为演员的成长梦想竞争？就像，有没有其他事情是你考虑过也许去大学学习的？没有。
No?
This was it.
You were all in.
Fucking dope.
I love that.
I was all in.
没有？就是这个。你全力以赴了。该死的，太棒了。我喜欢那个。我全力以赴了。我全力以赴了。我全力以赴了。
Mom and dad were okay with that?
What did they do?
They were okay with it.
My dad was in the finance world.
He was a stockbroker.
And my mom was a lawyer.
No pressure to go into either one of those professions from them?
Nope.
妈妈和爸爸对此没意见吗？他们是做什么的？他们没意见。我爸爸在金融界。他是个股票经纪人。我妈妈是个律师。他们没有压力让你进入这两个职业中的任何一个吗？没有。
My parents were really young when they had me.
They were 19 when they had me.
And they had me.
Wow.
had nothing when I was born, like, really, like, hustled and worked their way up in the 80s.
And, like, I learned from them, like, how to, you know, hustle.
And it didn't matter, like, what field you were in.
It was just, like, they're, that's what they taught me.
我父母生我的时候真的很年轻。他们生我的时候才19岁。他们生了我。哇。我出生时一无所有，就像，真的，就像，在80年代努力奋斗并一路打拼。而且，就像，我从他们那里学到了，就像，如何，你知道，奋斗。而且这并不重要，就像，你在哪个领域。这只是，就像，他们教我的。
And my mom, I think also, like, she went to night school when I was a baby to be a lawyer and stuff.
But she really introduced me to, like, Saturday Night Live.
And she loves theater and movies.
and I think in another life she would have been doing what I'm doing.
Oh, that's great.
Yeah, so.
So they've got to be thrilled for you then because you just are all self-created.
They're so psyched, yeah.
而且我妈妈，我想也是，就像，我在婴儿时期她去上夜校成为律师之类的。但她真的向我介绍了，就像，《周六夜现场》。她热爱戏剧和电影。而且我想在另一辈子，她会做我现在做的事。哦，那太棒了。是的，所以。所以他们一定为你感到激动，因为你完全是自力更生的。他们太兴奋了，是的。
Well, let's stay there with Saturday Night Live.
So you were a page at one point at 30 Rock.
Oh, that's cool.
I didn't know that.
And then a bunch of years later, she comes back and she hosts Saturday Night Live.
That must have been very surreal.
That was crazy.
cray cray, right?
好吧，让我们留在《周六夜现场》。所以你曾经在30 Rock做过接待员。哦，那很酷。我不知道。然后很多年后，她回来主持《周六夜现场》。那一定非常超现实。那太疯狂了。疯狂，对吧？
That was crazy.
I was a page 2005.
It was right after.
I can't remember it was after the stroke.
I think it was before the stroke.
I don't know, after the stroke.
But I was at an intern actually in the 30 Rock building.
Which is higher or lower on the power scale?
那太疯狂了。我2005年是接待员。那是在之后。我不记得是在中风之后。我想是在中风之前。我不知道，中风之后。但我实际上是30 Rock大楼里的实习生。在权力等级上是更高还是更低？
It's weirdly higher than a page.
Really?
You would think that because a intern doesn't get paid, but a page does, right?
But a page gets paid.
So you would think, but like, no.
The page works for the network and the interim works for the show.
Exactly.
And I was not a very good page.
它奇怪地比接待员高。真的吗？你会认为因为实习生没有报酬，但接待员有，对吧？但接待员有报酬。所以你会认为，但就像，不。接待员为电视网工作，实习生为节目工作。完全正确。而且我不是一个很好的接待员。
I was like fucking around too much.
What was your problem?
My problem was I was hung over pretty much every time.
So I would have to throw up in the trash cans in the hallway, like mid-door.
What does a page do there?
Well, if you don't get an assignment, which I never did, maybe once I got one,
which means like you get assigned to a different, a different,
show like the coveted position was the Saturday Night Live pages um to get assigned on
我当时就像该死地到处乱搞。你的问题是什么？我的问题是我几乎每次都宿醉。所以我不得不在走廊的垃圾桶里呕吐，就像在门中间。接待员在那里做什么？嗯，如果你没有得到任务，我从来没有，也许有一次我得到了一个，这意味着就像你被分配到一个不同的，不同的，节目，就像令人垂涎的职位是《周六夜现场》的接待员，嗯，被分配到
SNL but if you don't get a sign you're just giving tours you're you're you're on the circuit
you're giving tours oh yeah oh wow I get tours and then I would love to have yeah what would be so
great about being an SNL page um is it is it just the fact that you get to hang out there at the
desk and you like basically mission control where everyone is passing by and you just get to be there
You just get to watch what's going on and sit there.
It's pretty amazing.
And like meet celebrities and get them coffee and like whatever.
So then when you come back as a host, were you, did you talk with them more?
SNL，但如果你没有被分配，你只是在做导游，你，你，你在巡回，你在做导游。哦，是的，哦，哇，我做导游，然后我会喜欢有，是的，做SNL接待员最棒的是什么，嗯，是，是仅仅因为你可以在桌子旁闲逛，你就像基本上是任务控制中心，每个人都经过，你只是可以在那里。你只是可以看正在发生什么并坐在那里。这太神奇了。而且就像见到名人并给他们咖啡之类的。所以当你回来做主持人时，你，你和他们谈得更多了吗？
Did you, was it just sort of just like a private little level?
No, I would never talk to a page.
Never.
No, of course.
I mean, every time I go in that building, I'm like, you know, I still know the security guards.
Like it feels, you know, that.
building is so like it's such a family vibe there like it's the best and like i'm still i love
my bosses when i was because i was an intern at s nl and a page but i was an intern in the design
你，这只是某种私人小层面吗？不，我永远不会和接待员说话。从来不会。不，当然。我的意思是，每次我走进那栋楼，我都会想，你知道，我仍然认识保安。就像感觉，你知道，那栋楼就像，那里有一种家庭氛围，就像它是最好的，而且就像我仍然，我爱我的老板，当我因为我既是SNL的实习生又是接待员，但我是在设计
department with um you know akira and uh keith raywood and joe and eugene and um the design of the
sets or the costumes or the set designers for the show and then i did my when i hosted i did like
my monologue about that and I had those guys like come on stage it came totally came full
circle but they were all yeah I mean I love I love going back there was it emotional at all
when you yeah it's like it's tripped out it was very trippy it's like it's weird yeah it's very
weird when you so when you grew up you grew up in Delaware is that correct yeah and then and then
you moved right to New York right like when you're a kid yeah I mean I moved to
Yeah, to go to college.
部门实习，和，嗯，你知道，阿基拉和，嗯，基思·雷伍德和乔和尤金，嗯，布景设计或服装或节目的布景设计师，然后我做了我的，当我主持时，我做了关于那个的独白，我让那些家伙上台，这完全形成了一个完整的循环，但他们都，是的，我的意思是，我喜欢，我喜欢回到那里，当你，你，这有任何情感吗？是的，这就像，这很奇幻，这非常奇幻，这就像，这很奇怪，是的，这非常奇怪，当你，所以当你成长时，你在特拉华州成长，对吗？是的，然后，然后你直接搬到了纽约，对吧，就像当你是个孩子时？是的，我的意思是，我搬到了，是的，去上大学。
Oh, so Delaware, you know, up until you were at college
and then you went to college in New York.
Had you been to New York before then and seen it
and like, I want to go there and all that?
Yeah, I mean, yeah, because Delaware's really
only two hours south of the city.
People, like, think it's like five hours away.
It's really close.
哦，所以特拉华州，你知道，直到你上大学，然后你在纽约上大学。在那之前你去过纽约并看过它，就像，我想去那里之类的吗？是的，我的意思是，是的，因为特拉华州离城市真的只有两个小时的路程。人们，就像，认为它有五个小时远。它真的很近。
I take the train up all the time.
And then you went out to L.A.
So basically my question is,
because I was talking about Scotty
about living like in a small town,
town somewhere because we're constantly on either coast in New York or Los Angeles,
back and forth, back and forth all the time.
它真的很近。我一直坐火车上去。然后你去了洛杉矶。所以基本上我的问题是，因为我一直在和斯科蒂谈论住在某个小镇，因为我们一直在纽约或洛杉矶的海岸，来回，来回，一直这样。
And there's something appealing about living in a small town somewhere, like outside of a city,
but I think I might go out of my mind a little bit because I do need the...
You feel too isolated?
Yeah, and I do need the stimulation of the noise.
Are you like that?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I like the city.
I like New York.
住在某个小镇，就像城市外面，有一些吸引人的地方，但我认为我可能会有点疯，因为我确实需要……你感到太孤立了吗？是的，而且我确实需要噪音的刺激。你是那样的吗？是的，是的。是的，我喜欢城市。我喜欢纽约。
I'm back in New York.
Are you back in New York now?
I'm back in New York, baby.
You are?
Yeah.
I'm back in here.
So you wouldn't be able to move back to a small town again.
Sean, you wouldn't be able to do that either.
我回到纽约了。你现在回到纽约了吗？我回到纽约了，宝贝。你是吗？是的。我回到这里了。所以你无法再搬回小镇了。肖恩，你也不能那样做。
I don't think, I want to want it.
But I don't think I could, I would last.
Right.
But maybe.
I don't know.
Sometimes I feel like I could.
But where I grew up wasn't, there was a, it was a small town vibe in some ways,
but Wilmington, Delaware is like, it's a proper city also.
我不认为，我想想要它。但我不认为我能，我会坚持下去。但也许。我不知道。有时我觉得我可以。但我成长的地方不是，在某些方面有一种小镇氛围，但威尔明顿，特拉华州就像，它也是一个正经的城市。
So it's not like super.
And you want to raise your family in,
in a city like you are now.
Yeah, I mean, I wasn't, you know,
not totally thought through.
But I'm like, yeah, I mean, East Coast for sure.
My family's in Philadelphia and Delaware mainly.
Oh, great.
所以它不是超级。而且你想在，在城市里抚养你的家庭，就像你现在这样。是的，我的意思是，我没有，你知道，没有完全想清楚。但我就像，是的，我的意思是，东海岸肯定。我的家人主要在费城和特拉华州。哦，太棒了。
So I loved, like, one of the reasons I came back here was for that.
So I can get on the train and go home, you know.
Yeah.
My grandmother, yeah.
How are you when you go on a location,
like when you're shooting something that's in a faraway place,
Like a localeche?
Yeah, on location.
所以我喜欢，就像，我回到这里的原因之一就是为了那个。所以我可以坐火车回家，你知道。是的。我的祖母，是的。当你去外景地时，就像当你拍摄一个遥远地方的东西时，就像外景地？是的，在外景地。
Yeah, like White Lotus, for example.
Like, are you okay being disconnected from major cosmopolitan city for a long period of time?
Yeah, I'm, like, very adoptable.
Like, I feel like I would, I'm...
I go someplace and I'm there for one day and I'm like, this is it.
This is my life for the rest of my life.
Like, I'm very...
I think I would be okay, like, in jail.
是的，就像《白莲花度假村》，例如。就像，你习惯长期与主要的大都市城市断开连接吗？是的，我，就像，非常容易适应。就像，我觉得我会，我……我去某个地方，我在那里待一天，我就想，就是这个。这就是我余生的生活。就像，我非常……我想我会在监狱里，就像，也会没事的。
Like, I'd be like, this is it?
You just make it your home.
Right.
Yeah.
I'd be like, this is it.
This is what I have to eat, and this is where...
I say that when I get into an elevator.
就像，我会想，就是这个？你只是把它当作你的家。对。是的。是的。我会想，就是这个。这就是我必须吃的，这就是……我在电梯里时会这么说。
I'm like, if it breaks down, this is where I'm at.
I'm just here for several hours.
That's not true.
You kept...
You kept volume in your elevator in London.
This is a true story, Aubrey.
He kept a bottle of volume in his elevator at his place
我会想，如果它坏了，这就是我所在的地方。我只是在这里待几个小时。那不是真的。那不是真的。你在伦敦的电梯里保持了音量。这是一个真实的故事，奥布里。他在他的电梯里放了一瓶安定，在他住的地方
in case it broke down so he wouldn't freak out.
So this is an absolute fallacy what you're saying right now.
There's recent proof of you not being okay being stuck in an elevator.
But I went through, what is that therapy called?
I went through that therapy.
EMDR?
Yeah, what, no, like, what is it called?
Electro therapy.
以防它坏了，这样他就不会抓狂。所以你现在说的这完全是一个谬论。最近有证据表明你并不习惯被困在电梯里。但我经历了，那叫什么疗法？我经历了那种疗法。EMDR？是的，什么，不，就像，它叫什么？电疗。
When you go, you do the thing you're afraid of.
EMDR?
No, I forget what it's called.
Shock therapy.
Anyway, exposure, exposure therapy.
Okay.
Yeah, so I did that with an elevator.
On the subway?
当你去时，你做你害怕的事情。EMDR？不，我忘了它叫什么。休克疗法。不管怎样，暴露，暴露疗法。好的。是的，所以我对电梯做了那个。在地铁上？
You just open up your trench coat?
What's going on?
No, I did it.
I did exposure therapy and I got over it.
Let's talk about white.
Lotus for a second. Now, where did you shoot that?
Sicily.
你只是打开你的风衣？怎么了？不，我做了。我做了暴露疗法，我克服了它。让我们谈谈《白莲花度假村》一秒钟。现在，你在哪里拍的？西西里岛。西西里岛。
It was like four or five months in Sicily and then one month in Rome.
Wow. Wow. That's pretty nice.
That's pretty fun.
Yeah. That sounds pretty, pretty good.
It's pretty good.
Is everything okay, Jay?
Jay, are you okay?
I'm hearing something in the other room. It's probably the Alexa chirping off.
那是在西西里岛待了四五个月，然后在罗马待了一个月。哇。哇。那很不错。那很有趣。是的。那听起来很，很不错。那很不错。一切都好吗，杰伊？杰伊，你还好吗？我在隔壁房间听到了一些声音。那可能是Alexa在乱叫。
What the fuck?
So Jason just get attacked by a Roomba.
Did you...
His electronics are revolting.
Is it true that the scripts are really secretive
when you're doing White Lotus?
Like you're not allowed to like talk about them?
什么鬼？所以杰森刚刚被Roomba攻击了。你……他的电子产品在反抗。你……《白莲花度假村》拍摄时剧本真的很保密是真的吗？就像你不被允许谈论它们？
It's like doing Star Wars.
Did you have a problem with that?
I didn't have a problem with it, but yeah, I mean, you're not supposed to.
Because he writes all of them, so you get all of them.
You've read all of the episodes before you have.
Wow, that's so cool.
He being Mike White.
Mike White.
就像拍《星球大战》一样。你有这个问题吗？我没有问题，但是的，我的意思是，你不应该。因为他写了所有的，所以你得到了所有的。你在你有之前读过所有的剧集。哇，那太酷了。他就是迈克·怀特。迈克·怀特。
Right, but is there like, so there's a big, there's a big secret you can't say on these shows, right?
It's about somebody that dies, right?
You mean say to who?
To anyone, to the vote.
Like, what is, what are they're trying to keep it secret and locked down?
Oh, yeah.
Because at the center of each one of these seasons is the reveal.
Like a murder.
对，但有没有，所以有一个大，有一个大秘密你不能在这些节目中说，对吧？是关于某个人死了，对吧？你的意思是告诉谁？告诉任何人，告诉投票。就像，什么是，他们试图保持秘密并锁定？哦，是的。因为在这些季节的每一个中心都是揭示。就像谋杀。
Right, the murder mystery.
The murder.
Yeah, I mean, I didn't read other people's lines and other people.
I didn't even know.
Wait, you're not given the pages that you're not on?
No, she's giving them.
You are.
Oh, you are?
对，谋杀之谜。谋杀。是的，我的意思是，我没有读其他人的台词和其他人。我甚至不知道。等等，你没有得到你不在的页面？不，她给了他们。你是。哦，你是吗？
Oh, she's given them.
Don't worry.
I've heard of productions like that.
You're only given the scenes that you're in.
I just go bullshit, bullshit, my line.
Right.
Uh-huh.
哦，她给了他们。别担心。我听说过那样的制作。你只得到你在的场景。我只是去胡说八道，胡说八道，我的台词。对。嗯哼。对。
Remember?
Yeah.
No, I didn't read.
My season was different, or maybe slightly different because, or maybe it wasn't different.
I don't know the secrecy.
But I don't, yeah, I actually, like, I read the scripts, obviously,
but I was so focused on my
Right
记得吗？是的。不，我没有读。我的季节不同，或者可能略有不同，因为，或者可能它并不不同。我不知道保密性。但我没有，是的，我实际上，就像，我读了剧本，显然，但我太专注于我的，对，
You know storyline that I was
I didn't I didn't even
Really
Know what was going on
And the rest of the show at all
But I will say I just was
With Sandra Bernhardt
Who's gonna be on the next season
你知道故事情节，我没有，我甚至真的不知道发生了什么，在节目的其余部分。但我会说我刚刚和桑德拉·伯恩哈德在一起，她将参加下一季。
And I was hanging out with her last week
And I was and I was like
Did you get all the scripts?
And she was like, yeah
And I was and just nothing
And I didn't care
I'm not like trying to get the secret out of her
but like she had that white lotus
我上周和她在一起，我当时想，你得到所有的剧本了吗？她就像，是的，我当时想，什么都没有。我不在乎，我不是想从她那里得到秘密，但就像她有那种白莲花
look in her eye.
Sandra Burner.
You know it well.
Did you guys all see King of Comedy
way back in the day?
Of course.
One of my all-time favorite movies.
I love that movie.
眼神。桑德拉·伯恩哈德。你很了解它。你们都看过很久以前的《喜剧之王》吗？当然。我最喜欢的电影之一。我喜欢那部电影。
Aubrey, what do you have coming up
that you're super excited about?
Because I know you've got a lot of projects going on.
Oh, well, the main thing
that I believe this is like dropping
the day that this comes out,
which is today.
Which is,
奥布里，你有什么让你超级兴奋的事情吗？因为我知道你有很多项目正在进行。哦，好吧，主要的事情是我相信这就像在这一集发布的那天发布，也就是今天。也就是，
Kevin, my new animated series that I co-created and starred in and produced on Amazon Prime.
Oh, great.
Prime Video.
Excuse me.
And let's tell our listeners what that is about, this show Kevin.
So Kevin.
She said your voice is so long.
I know.
凯文，我的新动画系列，我共同创作并主演并制作，在亚马逊Prime上。哦，太棒了。Prime Video。抱歉。让我们告诉我们的听众关于这个节目，这个叫凯文的节目。所以凯文。她说你的声音太长了。我知道。
It's a lovely title.
Who is Kevin?
Oh, God.
Kevin is a cartoon based on a real true story that was.
was about my actual cat that I shared with Joe Wenger when we lived in Astoria Queens at the time
that we were talking about, Will, all the, that UCB era. And we had a cat named Kevin, who was an
alley cat. We actually had two cats, Kevin and Howard. They were brothers. But this Kevin survived longer.
So the show is about Kevin. But the show is basically about a couple that is living in Queens
这是一个可爱的标题。凯文是谁？哦，天哪。凯文是一部基于真实故事的卡通，是关于我当时和乔·温格在阿斯托利亚皇后区居住时共享的我的真实猫，威尔，所有那些，那个UCB时代。我们有一只叫凯文的猫，它是一只巷猫。我们实际上有两只猫，凯文和霍华德。它们是兄弟。但这只凯文活得更久。所以这个节目是关于凯文的。但这个节目基本上是关于一对住在皇后区的夫妇，
based on me and Joe that break up
and they have to tell their cat
because in the show,
animals and humans interact
and they tell Kevin like,
we're breaking up.
So who are you going with?
Me or him?
基于我和乔，他们分手了，他们必须告诉他们的猫，因为在节目中，动物和人类互动，他们告诉凯文，就像，我们要分手了。所以你要跟谁走？我还是他？
And Kevin's like,
you know what?
I'm not going with either of you.
I don't want to be with you.
I want to go out on my own
and be with the single cats.
And I want to play the field.
凯文就像，你知道吗？我哪一个都不跟。我不想和你在一起。我不想和你在一起。我想出去自己过，和单身猫在一起。我想玩玩。
So Kevin goes and lives at a shelter
with all the other single cats
and they kind of,
they date,
owners and decide, you know, negotiate with humans and decide, well, maybe I'll live with
this guy.
I don't know.
And who's playing Kevin?
所以凯文去了一个收容所，和所有其他单身猫住在一起，他们某种程度上，他们约会，主人并决定，你知道，与人类谈判并决定，嗯，也许我会和这个家伙住在一起。我不知道。谁在扮演凯文？
Kevin is a voice by Jason Schwartzman.
Nice.
Who's so funny because Kevin's this kind of like neurotic cat.
He's got a really messed up butthole that he's fixated on.
He's constantly talking about his weird butt hole in therapy.
Same.
And he's just got a lot of like interesting.
And Jason, Jason, Jason wrote the music.
凯文是由杰森·舒瓦兹曼配音的。不错。他太有趣了，因为凯文是那种神经质的猫。他有一个非常糟糕的肛门，他对此很着迷。他一直在治疗中谈论他奇怪的肛门。我也是。而且他只是有很多，就像，有趣的。而且杰森，杰森，杰森写了音乐。
Jason wrote the music for the show, too.
Jason wrote the theme song, which is so fucking catchy.
You know, Jason's a killer drummer.
Yeah, he's a crazy good drummer.
He's so talented.
Yes, he is.
Yeah, he wrote the theme song.
It's awesome.
杰森也为节目写了音乐。杰森写了主题曲，这太该死地朗朗上口了。你知道，杰森是一个杀手级鼓手。是的，他是一个疯狂的好鼓手。他太有才华了。是的，他是。是的，他写了主题曲。太棒了。
It has this, like, really, like, yeah, early 2000s, like indie rock vibe.
And then the cast is just insane.
It's like John Waters, plays Armando the Cat, who's this kind of...
That's great.
Wow.
snobby Persian cat,
um,
queen that lives in Queens.
它有这种，就像，真的，就像，21世纪初，就像独立摇滚氛围。而且演员阵容简直疯狂。就像约翰·沃特斯，扮演阿曼多猫，它是这种……那太棒了。哇。势利的波斯猫，嗯，住在皇后区的女王。
Um,
Whoopi Goldberg plays a hairless freak cat.
Amy Sedaris plays like a little yappy dog
that's bossing everybody around.
Oh,
man.
Um,
嗯，乌比·戈德堡扮演一只无毛怪猫。嗯，艾米·塞达里斯扮演一只爱叫的小狗，对每个人指手画脚。哦，天哪。嗯，
I play a human,
among other things.
I play a drunk spider and different kinds of characters.
That's great.
But you didn't have to play two or three characters,
you know,
you didn't run out of people you could have gone to.
I mean,
我扮演一个人，除其他外。我扮演一只醉蜘蛛和不同种类的角色。那太棒了。但你不必扮演两个或三个角色，你知道，你没有用完你可以找的人。我的意思是，
you got Will has done quite a bit of voice work.
Sean's done some, I've done some.
We can't afford it.
If you ever get tired of playing multiple characters, you know, just saying.
I will.
That is a really good cast.
Isn't it?
It's fucking stacked.
你有威尔做了相当多的配音工作。肖恩做了一些，我也做了一些。我们负担不起。如果你厌倦了扮演多个角色，你知道，只是说说而已。我会的。那是一个非常好的演员阵容。不是吗？它该死地堆满了。
And the guest stars are amazing.
The show's really, really funny.
We've been working on it since before the pandemic.
You know, animation takes so long.
So long.
And it's really funny.
I'm so proud of it.
I think people are going to love it.
而且客串明星太棒了。这个节目真的，真的很有趣。我们从疫情前就开始做了。你知道，动画需要很长时间。太长了。而且它真的很有趣。我为它感到骄傲。我想人们会喜欢它的。
Schwartzman used to do it.
to do a show, a weekly show
on Sirius XMU
where he'd play all sorts of
like, you know,
deep cuts.
Yeah, deep, independent music cuts.
And it was, it was so good.
舒瓦兹曼过去常做，做一个每周节目在Sirius XMU，他会播放各种，你知道，深度剪辑。是的，深度，独立音乐剪辑。而且它，它太好了。
I used to listen to it every week.
I'm such a fan of his in every way.
Yeah, his taste in music is so...
Really good.
So good.
Yeah, really, really good.
I wonder if he, is he, he's not...
I think he used to be in a band
我过去每周都听。我以各种方式都是他的粉丝。是的，他对音乐的品味太……真的很好。太好了。是的，真的，真的很好。我想知道他，他是，他不是……我想他过去在一个乐队里，
back in the day.
Yeah, he was in a band.
He's not like in a dad band now.
theme song to Orange County.
Isn't that right?
Yeah.
Oh, that show Orange County?
Yes.
在过去的日子里。是的，他在一个乐队里。他现在不像是在一个爸爸乐队里。奥兰治县的主题曲。不是吗？是的。哦，那个节目《奥兰治县》？是的。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, wasn't that on while we were doing
a rest of development?
It sure was.
But the same time, yeah.
哦，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。是的。是的。是的。等等，那不是在我们做《发展受阻》时播出的吗？确实是。但在同一时间，是的。
It sure was.
Yeah, I wonder if he's like in a dad band right now,
how great would that be.
That is cool.
Don't put him in that.
He can be...
Well, but he's a dad.
Okay.
确实是。是的，我想知道他现在是否在一个爸爸乐队里，那该多好。那很酷。别把他放进去。他可以是……好吧，但他是一个爸爸。好的。
But that doesn't need to be his identity, man.
No, it doesn't need to be his little side gig.
Side gig.
Well, listen, Aubrey, we hit it.
We did it.
We're two minutes past our time already.
I mean, you're amazing.
Aubrey, you're such a delight.
但这不需要成为他的身份，伙计。不，它不需要成为他的小副业。副业。好吧，听着，奥布里，我们做到了。我们做到了。我们已经超过时间两分钟了。我的意思是，你太棒了。奥布里，你真是个快乐。
Firing on all cylinders.
No, stop.
Congratulations on the incredible news.
That is awesome.
Oh, my God.
Really cool.
Really, really awesome.
Very great.
火力全开。不，停下。恭喜这个不可思议的消息。那太棒了。哦，天哪。真的很酷。真的，真的太棒了。非常棒。
Thank you guys.
And the birth of your new show today as well.
Good one, too.
Good one.
So just, you know, celebrations all around.
Thank you for doing this
For birthing this episode today
Fucking too much
谢谢你们。还有你今天新节目的诞生。也不错。不错。所以只是，你知道，到处都在庆祝。谢谢你做这个，为了今天诞生这一集，该死的太多了，
Too much
That was too much
We'll turn that later
Great to see you again, Aubrey
Plaza
Love you so much
Just so happy for you
Yeah, just so happy for you
太多了，那太多了，我们稍后会转那个。很高兴再次见到你，奥布里·普拉扎，非常爱你，真的为你感到高兴，是的，真的为你感到高兴，
You're the best
You're the best, huh?
You take care of yourself
All right
You hear me?
We're going to watch Kevin
你是最好的，你是最好的，嗯？你是最好的，你是最好的，照顾好你自己，好的，你听到了吗？我们要看凯文。
on Amazon Prime
Starting today
I'm logging on right now
Oh, you know, the reviews are in.
Meow, says the me, right.
Kitty likes to scratch, says the post.
It's the perfect show.
我们打算从今天开始在亚马逊Prime上看《凯文》。我现在就登录。哦，你知道，评论已经出来了。喵，猫咪说，对吧。帖子说，小猫喜欢抓挠。这是一部完美的剧。
There we go.
Don't ruin it for me.
Okay, you're right, you're right.
We love it.
We love you.
Thank you.
好了。别给我剧透。好吧，你是对的，你是对的。我们喜欢它。我们喜欢它。我们喜欢它。我们爱你。谢谢。
Enjoy your day.
Bye, honey.
All right, goodbye.
See you down the road.
Bye, Plaza.
Bye, yeah.
Bye.
There she goes.
祝你今天愉快。再见，亲爱的。好的，再见。路上见。再见，普拉扎。再见，是的。再见。她走了。
Aubrey Plaza.
There she came and there she went.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What a pleasure.
Yeah.
She's, I love, I love.
of her particular talent and taste and style.
奥布瑞·普拉扎。她来了又走了。是啊，是啊，是啊。真是荣幸。真是荣幸。是啊。我喜欢，我喜欢她独特的才华、品味和风格。
She's real cool, as the kids say.
She's really cool.
Yeah.
She just does something that I think a lot of actors
are not really comfortable doing,
which is, you know, like, I don't know.
Believing that they're enough.
Exactly, yeah, and that they're not screaming
她真的很酷，就像孩子们说的那样。她真的很酷。是啊。她做了一些我认为很多演员并不真正适应的事情，那就是，你知道，怎么说呢。相信他们自己已经足够好了。没错，是的，而且他们没有在向你大喊大叫
their performance at you, you know?
Yeah, I mean, she has just, she has so much,
I don't know, again, just sort of facility with all of it.
It's amazing.
And that, honestly, I mean, I always, I've always been a fan in sort of bias.
But then when I said last year when I saw that, Emily of the Criminal, it was just, it was like another layer, like another really rich heavy-duty layer.
I was like, wow, this kid, I'm not kid, that sounds almost, you know, this person is just got it all.
Yeah.
他们的表演，你知道吗？是啊，我的意思是，她有，她有太多的，我不知道，再次强调，就是那种对这一切的掌控力。太神奇了。而且，老实说，我的意思是，我一直，我一直都是她的粉丝，有点偏见。但去年当我看到那部《罪犯艾米丽》时，那简直是另一层，就像另一层非常丰富、沉重的内涵。我当时想，哇，这孩子，不是孩子，那听起来几乎，你知道，这个人简直拥有一切。是啊。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know?
Yeah.
And then I think about it, and then I look at J.B.
And I'm like, what is, what's missing?
You know, what's the thing?
How is he still going?
What a mystery.
是啊，是啊，是啊。你知道吗？是啊。然后我思考了一下，再看看J.B.。我就想，什么，缺了什么？你知道，那是什么东西？他怎么还在继续？真是个谜。
Because he's just so...
He's an enigma.
An enigma.
Well, no, it's not your ability.
As a talent, you're great.
You got so much talent.
But as a person, you're like,
you have the personality of a Waymo driver.
因为他太……他是个谜。一个谜。好吧，不，这不是你的能力问题。作为人才，你很棒。你很有才华。但作为一个人的话，你就像，你有着Waymo自动驾驶司机的个性。
You know what I mean?
I know.
I just leave you alone, mostly.
Yeah, I guess.
But I'm reliable, and I'll get you there on time.
I get you there.
But it's basically nothing.
Right?
你知道我的意思吗？我知道。我大多只是让你一个人待着。是啊，我想是吧。但我很可靠，我会准时把你送到那里。我把你送到那里。但基本上什么都没有。对吧？
You don't know what?
It's a robot.
Yeah, yeah.
It's big it.
But it's not even, like there's nothing.
Like, you put your hand in there.
Expensive, but, like, not even there.
So expensive.
你不知道什么？是个机器人。是啊，是啊。它很大。但甚至不是，就像什么都没有。就像，你把手伸进去。很贵，但是，就像，根本不存在。太贵了。
It's just a waste.
That's the other problem.
You're so, you've priced yourself out.
You know what I mean?
You have priced yourself out.
Shawnee, no, Shawnee.
Yeah, I have a goodbye.
Did you dig something up?
这简直是浪费。这是另一个问题。你太，你把自己定价过高了。你知道我的意思吗？你把自己定价过高了。肖尼，不，肖尼。是啊，我得走了。你挖出什么东西了吗？
Oh, I know you do.
Well, I was going to say, um, what's this hat today?
I don't know there's something about.
What's today's hat?
Oh, this is my high school.
It's a castle.
on a hill. Is that something that you purchased?
You don't wear a lot of things that you buy
哦，我知道你挖到了。嗯，我本来想说，嗯，今天的这顶帽子是什么？我不知道，有什么特别的。今天的帽子是什么？哦，这是我的高中。这是一座山上的城堡。那是你买的东西吗？你不太穿你买的东西
that you buy. No, they gave this to me.
Have you ever thrown out a freebie?
I know. I was like, this is like somebody's production
company. Yeah, see. I know.
And I'll bet the sweats are...
The sweats are the college, I went to.
Uh-huh.
The sweats are the college. The has the high school.
你买的。不，这是他们给我的。你有没有扔掉过赠品？我知道。我当时想，这就像是某人的制作公司。是啊，你看。我知道。我敢打赌这运动衫是……这运动衫是我上的大学。嗯哼。运动衫是大学的。帽子是高中的。
And this is somebody's company. I don't know what it is.
That is pretty crazy, isn't it?
I can't realize it until now.
It's so good.
Well, maybe one of these days you ought to get yourself out to a store and actually buy something.
Yeah, there we go.
Nice.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
而这是某人的公司。我不知道那是什么。这真是太疯狂了，不是吗？我直到现在才意识到。太棒了。好吧，也许有一天你应该去商店买点东西。是啊，就这样。不错。Smartless是100%有机的，由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant Terry手工制作。
Smartless.
Smartless。